Hi guys, good morning. Welcome. Welcome to another podcast. Hi, Sean. Hi, Will. And this is me. I'm here too. Hi, it's Jason. Hi. Oh, there he is. Sean. What's up, Sean? Yeah, Will. There he is. My guy Sean. Sean on the old smart list. Welcome to smartless with Will and Sean Hey JB speaking of the sidelines at the game last night, I got a text exchange with our buddy Hall of Fame former quarterback Peyton Manning and he said that I have I wear a visor
Hi guys, good morning. Welcome. Welcome to another podcast. Hi, Sean. Hi, Will. And this is me. I'm here too. Hi, it's Jason. Hi. Oh, there he is. Sean. What's up, Sean? Yeah, Will. There he is. My guy Sean. Sean on the old smart list. Welcome to smartless with Will and Sean Hey JB speaking of the sidelines at the game last night, I got a text exchange with our buddy Hall of Fame former quarterback Peyton Manning and he said that I have I wear a visor|||大家好，早安。欢迎。欢迎收听又一期播客。嗨，肖恩。嗨，威尔。这是我。我也在这。嗨，我是杰森。嗨。哦，他来了。肖恩。怎么了，肖恩？是的，威尔。他来了。我的好兄弟肖恩。肖恩上了老牌聪明榜。欢迎来到威尔和肖恩的聪明笨蛋秀。嘿，JB，说到昨晚比赛的场边，我和我们的老朋友、名人堂前四分卫佩顿·曼宁发了短信交流，他说我戴遮阳帽……
better than any non-athlete slash coach. I would agree. I would agree. Because you wear a good visor too. You haven't seen me in one. Yeah, we could skip it. I'm going to imagine it. Yeah, no, you do wear a good visor.
better than any non-athlete slash coach. I would agree. I would agree. Because you wear a good visor too. You haven't seen me in one. Yeah, we could skip it. I'm going to imagine it. Yeah, no, you do wear a good visor.|||比任何非运动员兼教练都好。我同意。我同意。因为你戴遮阳帽也很好看。你还没见过我戴呢。好吧，我们可以跳过这个。我会想象出来的。对，不，你戴遮阳帽确实挺好看的。
You got to have your beautiful long hair to really pull off a visor, or a hat in general. A hat with short hair, it's just too fifth grade. I think it just makes us all look like little tiny little farts that are late for the school bus. I mean, a visor or baseball hat. No, a hat of any sort. I think you need a little hair coming out the back,
You got to have your beautiful long hair to really pull off a visor, or a hat in general. A hat with short hair, it's just too fifth grade. I think it just makes us all look like little tiny little farts that are late for the school bus. I mean, a visor or baseball hat. No, a hat of any sort. I think you need a little hair coming out the back,|||你必须得有一头漂亮的秀发，才能真正驾驭遮阳帽，或者一般意义上的帽子。顶着短发戴帽子，感觉就像五年级的小学生。我觉得这让我们看起来都像快赶不上校车的乳臭未干的小屁孩。我是说，遮阳帽或棒球帽。不，任何种类的帽子。我觉得你后面得露出一点头发，
a little kick, a little kick out. Sean, if this feels like an attack, it's because it is. Yeah. I get it, I get it. Now Sean, walk us through, because the hat, your hat situation is loose at best. Yeah, what do you mean?
a little kick, a little kick out. Sean, if this feels like an attack, it's because it is. Yeah. I get it, I get it. Now Sean, walk us through, because the hat, your hat situation is loose at best. Yeah, what do you mean?|||稍微翘起来一点。肖恩，如果你觉得这是在攻击你，那是因为它就是。是的。我懂，我懂。好了，肖恩，给我们分析一下，因为这顶帽子，你的帽子情况最多只能算马马虎虎。对，你什么意思？
Well, you know, he always wears those hats that, you and I, Willie, we like those sort of, those trucker sort of type of high top. It's more of a higher crown. You like a slouch. Yeah, no, we like a baseball hat. No, I'm talking about... But your baseball hats make your head look like a baseball because they're very round on the top of it.
Well, you know, he always wears those hats that, you and I, Willie, we like those sort of, those trucker sort of type of high top. It's more of a higher crown. You like a slouch. Yeah, no, we like a baseball hat. No, I'm talking about... But your baseball hats make your head look like a baseball because they're very round on the top of it.|||嗯，你知道的，他总是戴那种帽子，你和我，威利，我们喜欢那种卡车司机帽那类的高顶帽。帽冠更高一些。你喜欢软帽。对，不，我们喜欢棒球帽。不，我说的是……但你们的棒球帽让你们的头看起来像个棒球，因为它们的顶部非常圆。
They have no crown to it, right? We like a shape to ours. We like a shape. A little bit of a wall. I feel like your trucker hats make your head look square. F you, bro. Yeah, we like a shape. Yeah, a little bit of a wall. I feel like your trucker hats make your heads look square. F you, bro. Yeah, F you, dog. How dare you insult us.
They have no crown to it, right? We like a shape to ours. We like a shape. A little bit of a wall. I feel like your trucker hats make your head look square. F you, bro. Yeah, we like a shape. Yeah, a little bit of a wall. I feel like your trucker hats make your heads look square. F you, bro. Yeah, F you, dog. How dare you insult us.|||它们没有帽冠，对吧？我们喜欢有造型的帽子。我们喜欢有造型的。有点棱角的。我觉得你的卡车司机帽让你的头看起来方方的。去你的，兄弟。对，我们喜欢有造型的。对，有点棱角的。我觉得你的卡车司机帽让你的头看起来方方的。去你的，兄弟。对，去你的，老兄。你怎么敢侮辱我们。
We just spent 10 minutes insulting you, how dare you insult us. This is not the way this works. Hey, Sean, now what is, can you, what is the hat you're wearing today? What is that, the GW? GW, Glendale West High School, the best high school in America,
We just spent 10 minutes insulting you, how dare you insult us. This is not the way this works. Hey, Sean, now what is, can you, what is the hat you're wearing today? What is that, the GW? GW, Glendale West High School, the best high school in America,|||我们刚刚花了10分钟侮辱你，你怎么敢侮辱我们。事情不是这样的。嘿，肖恩，现在是，你能说说你今天戴的是什么帽子吗？那是什么，GW？GW，格伦代尔西部高中，全美最好的高中，
in Glen Ellyn, Illinois, where I was born. Shout out! Shout out! Hey, did you guys ever see the movie Lucas? How is it the best high school in America? Well, I'm gonna tell you, did you ever see the movie Lucas? Remember Lucas?
in Glen Ellyn, Illinois, where I was born. Shout out! Shout out! Hey, did you guys ever see the movie Lucas? How is it the best high school in America? Well, I'm gonna tell you, did you ever see the movie Lucas? Remember Lucas?|||位于伊利诺伊州格伦埃林，我的出生地。大声喊出来！大声喊出来！嘿，你们看过电影《美国小子》吗？怎么就成全美最好的高中了？好吧，我来告诉你，你们看过电影《美国小子》吗？还记得《美国小子》吗？
Yeah. With Corey Haim, Winona Ryder's first film. Yep. Charlie Sheen. I feel like I read for that film. Really? Yeah, or at least I met with the writer-director, I think, afterwards. That was filmed with the writer director, I think afterwards.
With Corey Haim, Winona Ryder's first film. Yep. Charlie Sheen. I feel like I read for that film. Really? Yeah, or at least I met with the writer-director, I think afterwards. That was filmed with the writer director, I think afterwards.|||主演有科瑞·海姆，薇诺娜·赖德的第一部电影。对。查理·辛。我觉得我当时为那部电影试镜过。真的吗？对，或者至少我后来见过了编剧兼导演，我想是的。那是和编剧兼导演一起拍的，我想是后来。
That was filmed in my hometown at my high school. I was an extra, but you can't see me. That's what- I'm out of frame. Okay. That means you did your extra job well. That's right. You're supposed to go kind of unnoticed. Right, I committed off camera.
That was filmed in my hometown at my high school. I was an extra, but you can't see me. That's what- I'm out of frame. Okay. That means you did your extra job well. That's right. You're supposed to go kind of unnoticed. Right, I committed off camera.|||那是在我的家乡、我的高中拍摄的。我演了个群众演员，但你看不见我。这就是——我出画了。好吧。那说明你群众演员的工作做得很好。没错。你本就该默默无闻。对，我是在画外奉献的。
Yeah. So how was dinner on Saturday? Didn't we all have fun? Wasn't it fun? That was really fun. It was fun, it felt short. It felt like it wasn't quite as long as I wanted it. Well you left early because you had a kid pick up to do.
Yeah. So how was dinner on Saturday? Didn't we all have fun? Wasn't it fun? That was really fun. It was fun, it felt short. It felt like it wasn't quite as long as I wanted it. Well you left early because you had a kid pick up to do.|||对。那么周六的晚餐怎么样？大家是不是都玩得很开心？是不是很有趣？真的很有趣。很有趣，就是觉得时间过得太快了。感觉没我想象的那么久。好吧，你走得早，因为你要去接孩子。
I did, but did it go on much? Did you guys get into games at all? No, we didn't do games this year, did we? How come we don't play games anymore? Remember, Shawna, you used to have a full blown game night at your house years ago. Nobody's into them, and it's so much work. I can't do it, I can't do it,
I did, but did it go on much? Did you guys get into games at all? No, we didn't do games this year, did we? How come we don't play games anymore? Remember, Shawna, you used to have a full blown game night at your house years ago. Nobody's into them, and it's so much work. I can't do it, I can't do it,|||我是去了，但后来持续了很久吗？你们玩游戏了吗？不，我们今年没玩游戏，对吧？怎么我们现在不玩游戏了？记得吗，肖娜，你几年前还在家里举办过盛大的游戏之夜呢。没人对这个感兴趣了，而且太麻烦了。我搞不定，我搞不定，
because some people are into it, some people aren't. Why did that go away? I feel like game night was sort of like a big nationwide sort of trend for a while. I mean, we did that movie, too, that was sort of... I love that movie. Kind of at the end of it. Dude, that movie, Game Night,
because some people are into it, some people aren't. Why did that go away? I feel like game night was sort of like a big nationwide sort of trend for a while. I mean, we did that movie, too, that was sort of... I love that movie. Kind of at the end of it. Dude, that movie, Game Night,|||因为有些人感兴趣，有些人不感兴趣。为什么这种活动消失了？我觉得游戏之夜有一段时间就像是全国性的大潮流。我是说，我们拍的那部电影也是，有点……我超喜欢那部电影。差不多在它的结尾。老兄，那部电影《游戏之夜》，
I think we've talked about it on here before, if you haven't seen Jason's movie Game Night with Jason and- Run to the theater. No, if I'm going to be really honest, I put it on the other night with Franny and Maple and I had to turn it off in 10 minutes. Yeah, you said you didn't like it.
I think we've talked about it on here before, if you haven't seen Jason's movie Game Night with Jason and- Run to the theater. No, if I'm going to be really honest, I put it on the other night with Franny and Maple and I had to turn it off in 10 minutes. Yeah, you said you didn't like it.|||我想我们以前在这里讨论过，如果你还没看过杰森的电影《游戏之夜》，主演有杰森和——快去电影院看吧。不，老实说，前几天我和弗兰妮还有梅珀一起放这部电影看，结果不到十分钟我就不得不把它关掉了。对，你说过你不喜欢它。
I think it's one of the funniest movies ever. I may have been in a bad mood or something, but I was just like, oh guys, this is, I remember this being better. No, Jason, you said you didn't like it. I think it's one of the funniest movies ever. I may have been in a bad mood or something, but I was just like, oh guys, I remember this being better. No, Jason, I hate to say it. But I thought those guys did a great job with that film, but it wasn't for me the other night. You are wrong, you are wrong.
I think it's one of the funniest movies ever. I may have been in a bad mood or something, but I was just like, oh guys, this is, I remember this being better. No, Jason, you said you didn't like it. I think it's one of the funniest movies ever. I may have been in a bad mood or something, but I was just like, oh guys, I remember this being better. No, Jason, I hate to say it. But I thought those guys did a great job with that film, but it wasn't for me the other night. You are wrong, you are wrong.|||我觉得这是有史以来最好笑的电影之一。我可能当时心情不好什么的，但我当时就想，哦伙计们，这，我记得这部电影没这么差。不，杰森，你说过你不喜欢它。我觉得这是有史以来最好笑的电影之一。我可能当时心情不好什么的，但我当时就想，哦伙计们，我记得这部电影没这么差。不，杰森，我讨厌这么说。但我认为那些家伙把那部电影拍得很棒，但那天晚上它不适合我。你错了，你错了。
That, no, you're wrong. That movie is so funny, and I've seen it a few times. I've seen it within the last year. If it's on, I think- I was in a weird mood, maybe. I'll watch it within the last year. If it's on. I was in a weird mood maybe. I'll watch it. No, but you just, ah, Jesse Plemons, Jesse Plemons in that movie, incredible.
That, no, you're wrong. That movie is so funny, and I've seen it a few times. I've seen it within the last year. If it's on, I think- I was in a weird mood, maybe. I'll watch it within the last year. If it's on. I was in a weird mood maybe. I'll watch it. No, but you just, ah, Jesse Plemons, Jesse Plemons in that movie, incredible.|||那，不，你错了。那部电影太搞笑了，我都看过好几次了。我去年还看过的。如果在播的话，我想——我当时可能心情有点怪。我去年看过的。如果在播的话。我当时可能心情有点怪。我会看的。不，但你就是，啊，杰西·普莱蒙，杰西·普莱蒙在那部电影里，太绝了。
By the way, Billy Magnusson, that actor, Billy Magnusson. He's so good. So funny, he and Jesse, and obviously you and Rachel McAdams. Sharon Horgan was awesome in it too. Sharon Horgan is amazing in it. Sharon Horgan.
By the way, Billy Magnusson, that actor, Billy Magnusson. He's so good. So funny, he and Jesse, and obviously you and Rachel McAdams. Sharon Horgan was awesome in it too. Sharon Horgan is amazing in it. Sharon Horgan.|||顺便说一句，比利·马格努森，那个演员比利·马格努森。他太棒了。太搞笑了，他和杰西，还有显而易见的你和瑞秋·麦克亚当斯。莎伦·霍根在里面也很棒。莎伦·霍根在里面惊艳绝伦。莎伦·霍根。
What a cast, and if I'm leaving anybody out, it's because I can't remember. I gotta watch it again. Oh, and another thing that happened at dinner, Jason and I look over to you, Will, and you weren't even conscious of it. You had like a bowl or a cup or something, and you stuck your finger in it,
What a cast, and if I'm leaving anybody out, I'm because I can't remember. I gotta watch it again. Oh, and another thing that happened at dinner, Jason and I look over to you, Will, and you weren't even conscious of it. You had like a bowl or a cup or something, and you stuck your finger in it,|||多棒的演员阵容啊，如果我漏掉了谁，那是因为我记不清了。我得再看一遍。哦，晚餐时还有一件事，杰森和我看着你，威尔，你当时甚至都没意识到。你手里拿着个碗还是杯子什么的，然后把手指伸了进去，
and you were really grinding your finger around in a circle to get every last drop of whatever it was and then right in your mouth. It was chocolate syrup. Like you were in prison. It was chocolate syrup. Yeah, it was own little bowl dedicated to the chocolate syrup.
and you were really grinding your finger around in a circle to get every last drop of whatever it was and then right in your mouth. It was chocolate syrup. Like you were in prison. It was chocolate syrup. Yeah, it was own little bowl dedicated to the chocolate syrup.|||用手指在里面拼命转圈搅拌，为了把里面的最后一滴什么东西都刮干净，然后直接放进嘴里。那是巧克力糖浆。就像在监狱里一样。那是巧克力糖浆。对，那是专门盛巧克力糖浆的小碗。
I guess he asked for it on the side. And it wasn't to pour on anything. It was just for him to put his fat finger in it and just stir it around and stick it in his mouth like some kind of seductive freak. I wasn't trying to do it to seduce anybody I was doing because it was delicious and as you know, I have timed out my weekly cheat meal,
I guess he asked for it on the side. And it wasn't to pour on anything. It was just for him to put his fat finger in it and just stir it around and stick it in his mouth like some kind of seductive freak. I wasn't trying to do it to seduce anybody I was doing because it was delicious and as you know, I have timed out my weekly cheat meal,|||我猜他是另外要的。而且不是为了倒在什么东西上。纯粹是为了把胖乎乎的手指伸进去搅和搅和，然后塞进嘴里，就像个某种诱惑人的怪胎。我这么做可不是为了诱惑任何人，我这么做是因为它太好吃了，而且如你们所知，我把每周的欺骗餐时间掐得很准，
one meal to that meal and it worked out that it happened. But we're eating over at Jen's three nights a week now. Okay, so. No, I'm not doing it three nights a week. I'm doing it once. All right. Yeah. Speaking of deliciousness, let's get to our guest. Guys, this is really exciting.
one meal to that meal and it worked out that it happened. But we're eating over at Jen's three nights a week now. Okay, so. No, I'm not doing it three nights a week. I'm doing it once. All right. Yeah. Speaking of deliciousness, let's get to our guest. Guys, this is really exciting.|||刚好就碰上了那一餐。不过我们现在一周有三个晚上在简家吃饭。好吧，所以。不，我不是一周吃三个晚上。我一周去一次。好吧。对。说到美味，让我们来介绍我们的嘉宾。伙计们，这真的让人兴奋。
You're gonna be blown away. This is so exciting. Okay. Because this involves science. Great. Yes. Science. These goddamn celebrities on this show.
You're gonna be blown away. This is so exciting. Okay. Because this involves science. Great. Yes. Science. These goddamn celebrities on this show.|||你们绝对会大吃一惊的。太让人兴奋了。好吧。因为这涉及科学。太棒了。是的。科学。这个节目里的这些该死的名人啊。
I know. Well, he's kind of a celebrity. He's an author, a media personality, and the former head of the Advanced Aerospace Threat Identification Program at the Pentagon. I'm so excited. What I used to do. I'm so excited.
I know. Well, he's kind of a celebrity. He's an author, a media personality, and the former head of the Advanced Aerospace Threat Identification Program at the Pentagon. I'm so excited. What I used to do. I'm so excited.|||我知道。好吧，他某种程度上也算个名人。他是一位作家、媒体人，也是五角大楼先进航空航天威胁识别计划的前负责人。我太兴奋了。我以前做过的工作。我太兴奋了。
Always. I really am. I know, me too. He oversaw counter-espionage and counter-terrorism investigations worldwide for the Department of Defense, while also working for the National Counterintelligence Executive and the Director of National Intelligence,
Always. I really am. I know, me too. He oversaw counter-espionage and counter-terrorism investigations worldwide for the Department of Defense, while also working for the National Counterintelligence Executive and the Director of National Intelligence,|||一直都很兴奋。我真的是。我知道，我也是。他曾为国防部监督全球范围内的反间谍和反恐调查，同时还为国家反间谍执行官和国家情报总监工作，
very recently. Jason, that's your forte, right? Counterintelligence, right? Like the opposite. Right, yes. Get dumber, call me. Very recently, and I was watching, and this is like a week or two ago,
very recently. Jason, that's your forte, right? Counterintelligence, right? Like the opposite. Right, yes. Get dumber, call me. Very recently, and I was watching, and this is like a week or two ago,|||就在不久前。杰森，那是你的强项吧？反间谍，对吧？就像对立面一样。对，是的。变蠢了就找我。就在不久前，我当时在看，大概是一两周前吧，
he was testifying under oath to Congress about the importance of certain, let's call them X files being public knowledge But today he's talking to us dumb-dumbs. It's the very brilliant and super cool Luis Elizondo Good morning, sir Hi, gentlemen. Yeah, good morning. It is my honor privilege to be with you gents Likewise, this is so cool. I wanted to talk to you for years. I think- I'm so happy you've brought him on.
he was testifying under oath to Congress about the importance of certain, let's call them X files being public knowledge But today he's talking to us dumb-dumbs. It's the very brilliant and super cool Luis Elizondo Good morning, sir Hi, gentlemen. Yeah, good morning. It is my honor privilege to be with you gents Likewise, this is so cool. I wanted to talk to you for years. I think- I'm so happy you've brought him on.|||他在国会宣誓作证，讲述某些——我们姑且称之为《X档案》的机密文件公之于众的重要性。但今天他却在和我们这些笨蛋聊天。他就是极其才华横溢、超级酷的路易斯·埃利松多。早安，先生。嗨，各位先生。是的，早安。能与诸位共事是我的荣幸。彼此彼此，太酷了。我几年来一直想和你聊聊。我想——我太高兴你们把他请来了。
I know. I don't, I know how you're going to explain all this to us. Welcome. Welcome. Sean, do you want to get right to it? You want to ask him about the UFOs? Cause we can wait. No, hang on.
I know. I don't, I know how you're going to explain all this to us. Welcome. Welcome. Sean, do you want to get right to it? You want to ask him about the UFOs? Cause we can wait. No, hang on.|||我知道。我不知道，我不知道你打算怎么向我们解释这一切。欢迎。欢迎。肖恩，你想直接切入正题吗？你想问他关于UFO的事吗？因为我们可以等等。不，等等。
Let's just say, hi, I'm so excited you're here. You have just raised the bar. You've just made, cause we've had idiots like Conan on here a bunch. Oh, this guy. And Farrell. Are you familiar with him? we've had idiots like Conan on here a bunch. Oh, this guy. And Farrell. Are you familiar with him? He's the redheaded fellow with the talk show.
Let's just say, hi, I'm so excited you're here. You have just raised the bar. You've just made, cause we've had idiots like Conan on here a bunch. Oh, this guy. And Farrell. Are you familiar with him? we've had idiots like Conan on here a bunch. Oh, this guy. And Farrell. Are you familiar with him? He's the redheaded fellow with the talk show.|||咱们先说，嗨，你来这里我太兴奋了。你把标准拔高了。你刚刚让，因为我们请过像柯南这样的白痴来好多次了。哦，这家伙。还有法瑞尔。你熟悉他吗？我们请过像柯南这样的白痴来好多次了。哦，这家伙。还有法瑞尔。你熟悉他吗？就是那个主持脱口秀的红发家伙。
Just an absolute ding-dong. I might have heard of his name a few times. Investigate him, please, by the way. Also, just feel free to get into his. Listen, I gotta apologize, guys, for wearing a hat. I know, unfortunately, I'm one of those guys who has short hair and has to wear a hat because I have an unusually hemispherically round head.
Just an absolute ding-dong. I might have heard of his name a few times. Investigate him, please, by the way. Also, just feel free to get into his. Listen, I gotta apologize, guys, for wearing a hat. I know, unfortunately, I'm one of those guys who has short hair and has to wear a hat because I have an unusually hemispherically round head.|||简直是个十足的笨蛋。我可能听过几次他的名字。顺便请调查一下他。另外，尽管进入他的。听着，伙计们，我得为戴着帽子向大家道歉。我知道，不幸的是，我是那种头发很短、不得不戴帽子的人，因为我的头呈不同寻常的半球形圆形。
And so my wife forces me to wear a hat. She's like, otherwise I look like a bowling ball, so forgive me. Listen, you don't need to be forgiven. Forgive us, and if anything, you should fight Jason, obviously, physically. He looks like he could really take care of me. I know, right? No, remind your wife's do that. He looks like he could really take care of me.
And so my wife forces me to wear a hat. She's like, otherwise I look like a bowling ball, so forgive me. Listen, you don't need to be forgiven. Forgive us, and if anything, you should fight Jason, obviously, physically. He looks like he could really take care of me. I know, right? No, remind your wife's do that. He looks like he could really take care of me.|||所以我老婆逼我戴帽子。她说，否则我看起来就像个保龄球，所以请原谅我。听着，你不需要被原谅。原谅我们吧，如果要说的话，你显然应该在体能上和杰森打一架。他看起来真的很能收拾我。我懂，对吧？不，提醒你老婆那么做。他看起来真的很能收拾我。
No, remind your wife the goal of the head is to be round. So tell her to just back off a little. Well, yeah, I've said that a few times. Unfortunately, after 30 years of marriage, I've learned early on that happy wife, happy life. So when she says wear a hat, I wear a hat. Isn't that the truth, right? You've really got to pick your battles
No, remind your wife the goal of the head is to be round. So tell her to just back off a little. Well, yeah, I've said that a few times. Unfortunately, after 30 years of marriage, I've learned early on that happy wife, happy life. So when she says wear a hat, I wear a hat. Isn't that the truth, right? You've really got to pick your battles|||不，提醒你老婆，头长得圆是正常的。所以告诉她稍微让步一点。好吧，是的，我已经说过好几次了。不幸的是，经过30年的婚姻，我早就懂得了“老婆开心，生活顺心”的道理。所以当她说戴帽子时，我就戴帽子。难道不是吗？你真的得有所选择地去争吵，
if you want to stay married. You've just got to be able to say you are right nine times out of 10 if you want to keep it harmonious. I always say happy ex-wife, happy life. That to me is even, that applies even more. And don't make the mistake of telling them what you're thinking, because that is the- Well, I don't have that option.
if you want to stay married. You've just got to be able to say you are right nine times out of 10 if you want to keep it harmonious. I always say happy ex-wife, happy life. That to me is even, that applies even more. And don't make the mistake of telling them what you're thinking, because that is the- Well, I don't have that option.|||如果你想维持婚姻的话。为了保持和谐，你必须得做到十次有九次承认自己是对的。我总是说“前妻开心，生活顺心”。对我和说，这个甚至，这个更适用。而且千万别犯傻把心里的想法告诉她们，因为那是——好吧，我可没有那种选项。
My wife made it very clear to me that if, for whatever reason, we were ever to have a divorce, I'd have to buy back my own underwear from her, so. Wow, okay, wow. Yeah, I prefer to stay in the current relationship I have right now. Pretty ironclad agreement. Sean, you guys do that, right?
My wife made it very clear to me that if, for whatever reason, we were ever to have a divorce, I'd have to buy back my own underwear from her, so. Wow, okay, wow. Yeah, I prefer to stay in the current relationship I have right now. Pretty ironclad agreement. Sean, you guys do that, right?|||我老婆向我明确表态，如果出于某种原因我们离婚了，我得从她手里把自己的内衣买回来，所以。哇，好吧，哇。是的，我还是倾向于保持我目前的这段关系。相当铁板钉钉的协议。肖恩，你们也是这样的吧？
You and Scott do not share your own personal opinions. You just keep a nice neutral stance on everything. You know what's great about being in a gay relationship is if sometimes I have help come over and help with laundry and stuff, and if she mixes up our clothes, I just put them on, it doesn't matter. You're right. Ready? Yeah, that's a good point. That just put them on, it doesn't matter. Ready?
You and Scott do not share your own personal opinions. You just keep a nice neutral stance on everything. You know what's great about being in a gay relationship is if sometimes I have help come over and help with laundry and stuff, and if she mixes up our clothes, I just put them on, it doesn't matter. You're right. Ready? Yeah, that's a good point. That just put them on, it doesn't matter. Ready?|||你和斯科特不会分享各自的个人观点。你们对每件事都保持很好的中立立场。你知道同性恋关系最棒的一点是什么吗，就是有时我找人来帮忙洗衣服什么的，如果她把我们的衣服混在一起了，我直接穿上就行，没关系。你说得对。准备好了吗？对，说得好。直接穿上就行，没关系。准备好了吗？
Yeah, that's a good point. It doesn't matter if it's in an opposite drawer or something, I just put whatever it is. I like the way you say help with the laundry, I feel like you're standing there too. But what about the way you said, every once in a while, I'll call for some help to come over with the laundry. You mean every once in a while,
Yeah, that's a good point. It doesn't matter if it's in an opposite drawer or something, I just put whatever it is. I like the way you say help with the laundry, I feel like you're standing there too. But what about the way you said, every once in a while, I'll call for some help to come over with the laundry. You mean every once in a while,|||对，说得好。不管是放在哪个相反的抽屉里还是什么的，拿到什么我就穿什么。我喜欢你说的“帮忙洗衣服”，我感觉你当时也站在那儿。但你刚才那种说法呢，“偶尔我会叫人来帮忙洗衣服”。你是说偶尔，
like every Tuesdays and Thursdays? Monday through Friday, good for you, or? As long as they don't park where the chef parks, everything is all right, by the way. Anyway, let's get into counter-intelligism. This is so cool. Counter-intelligism. Yeah.
like every Tuesdays and Thursdays? Monday through Friday, good for you, or? As long as they don't park where the chef parks, everything is all right, by the way. Anyway, let's get into counter-intelligism. This is so cool. Counter-intelligism. Yeah.|||比如每周二和周四？周一到周五，真为你高兴，还是？顺便说一句，只要他们不把车停在主厨停车的地方，就一切都好。不管怎样，我们进入反间谍领域吧。太酷了。反间谍。对。
And thank you in advance for slowing things down and really dumbing it up for us, because like I said, I've been waiting to talk to you forever. I just think it's fascinating what you do and that you've come forward to want to explain to us, the citizens of this country and people who's ever listening about the things that kind of have been hidden
And thank you in advance for slowing things down and really dumbing it up for us, because like /I said, I've been waiting to talk to you forever. I just think it's fascinating what you do and that you've come forward to want to explain to us, the citizens of this country and people who's ever listening about the things that kind of have been hidden|||预先感谢你把语速放慢，并为我们把内容讲得通俗易懂，因为就像我说的，我等了你一辈子想跟你聊聊。我只是觉得你做的事情太迷人了，而且你愿意站出来向我们——这个国家的公民以及所有收听节目的听众——解释那些被隐藏起来的事情，
or whatever you've learned. But my first question, because I just watched you on TV in front of Congress, what, two weeks ago or something like that? What is it like to be asked so many questions about UAPs, and please explain what UAP means, that you either can't answer because of security or you know answering truthfully will blow our minds?
or whatever you've learned. But my first question, because I just watched you on TV in front of Congress, what, two weeks ago or something like that? What is it like to be asked so many questions about UAPs, and please explain what UAP means, that you either can't answer because of security or you know answering truthfully will blow our minds?|||或者你所了解到的一切。但我的第一个问题是，因为我刚在电视上看到你在国会面前作证，大概是什么两周前吧？被问到那么多关于UAP的问题（请解释一下UAP是什么意思），而你要么因为安全原因无法回答，要么知道如实回答会让我们大跌眼镜，那是一种什么样的体验？
Yeah, so great question. And again, thank you very much for having me on this wonderful program of yours. You know, when you're testifying before Congress and the American people, it's under oath. So you definitely need to keep your facts straight and remember that everything you're saying is for the record and it's indelible,
Yeah, so great question. And again, thank you very much for having me on this wonderful program of yours. You know, when you're testifying before Congress and the American people, it's under oath. So you definitely need to keep your facts straight and remember that everything you're saying is for the record and it's indelible,|||是的，问得好。再次非常感谢邀请我参加你们这个美妙的节目。你知道，当你在国会和美国人民面前作证时，这是在宣誓下的。所以你绝对需要确保事实准确，并记住你所说的一切都是为了记录在案且不可磨灭的，
meaning those words will be there forever, long after I'm gone and whatnot. So it's important that we communicate clearly, but at the same time, you're right, I have a security clearance, and I cannot violate that security clearance. The Pentagon was very, very specific with me on what I can and cannot say in an open hearing.
meaning those words will be there forever, long after I'm gone and whatnot. So it's important that we communicate clearly, but at the same time, you're right, I have a security clearance, and I cannot violate that security clearance. The Pentagon was very, very specific with me on what I can and cannot say in an open hearing.|||这意味着这些话将永远存在，远远在我离开之后等等。所以我们进行清晰的沟通很重要，但与此同时，你说得对，我有安全许可，我不能违反该安全许可。五角大楼对我能在公开听证会上说什么、不能说什么有着非常非常明确的规定。
And so that's why you saw me a few times when I said, look, I prefer to have that discussion in a closed session, because then we can start talking about some of the classified nuances of what they're asking me. And by the way, it's a bit of a precarious situation, because if you don't say enough, then Congress feels that it's kind of like fast food, right?
And so that's why you saw me a few times when I said, look, I prefer to have that discussion in a closed session, because then we can start talking about some of the classified nuances of what they're asking me. And by the way, it's a bit of a precarious situation, because if you don't say enough, then Congress feels that it's kind of like fast food, right?|||所以这就是为什么你会看到我有几次说，听着，我更倾向于在闭门会议中讨论这个问题，因为那样我们就可以开始谈论他们向我提问的一些机密细节。顺便说一句，这有点处境微妙，因为如果你说得不够多，国会就会觉得这有点像快餐，对吧？
You feel full, but you're not really satisfied. You get some information, but you're not really getting what you're asking for. But at the same time, if I'm overly specific, then I can get in trouble with the US government. I can actually find myself in very significant legal trouble, and for the record, I do not look good in an orange jumpsuit.
You feel full, but you're not really satisfied. You get some information, but you're not really getting what you're asking for. But at the same time, if I'm overly specific, then I can get in trouble with the US government. I can actually find myself in very significant legal trouble, and for the record, I do not look good in an orange jumpsuit.|||你感觉饱了，但并没有真正满足。你得到了一些信息，但并没有真正得到你所要求的。但与此同时，如果我过于具体，我就会惹上美国政府的麻烦。我实际上可能会陷入非常严重的法律麻烦，而且郑重声明，我穿橙色囚服一点也不好看。
So try to avoid that as much as possible. But if the purpose of the hearing is to gather information for the public and sort of march towards transparency, otherwise why sit in front of a microphone and share it? If you're not able to get all the information out, then is the expectation or the hope is that the public would be pleased with and satisfied with just half
So try to avoid that as much as possible. But if the purpose of the hearing is to gather information for the public and sort of march towards transparency, otherwise why sit in front of a microphone and share it? If you're not able to get all the information out, then is the expectation or the hope is that the public would be pleased with and satisfied with just half|||所以要尽最大努力避免这种情况。但如果听证会的目的是为公众收集信息并朝着透明度迈进，否则为什么要坐在麦克风前分享呢？如果你不能把所有的信息都抖露出来，那么人们的期望或希望是公众会因为只得到一半的信息而感到高兴和满足吗？
the information that you're able to share? Yeah, unfortunately that's not the case. The public's never happy with half information. And I understand that. Frankly, I would get frustrated too. But if you look at this conversation as it's kind of evolved over the last, let's say, seven years, I think we've come further in this conversation in the last seven than perhaps over the last, let's say, seven years. I think we've come further in this conversation
the information that you're able to share? Yeah, unfortunately that's not the case. The public's never happy with half information. And I understand that. Frankly, I would get frustrated too. But if you look at this conversation as it's kind of evolved over the last, let's say, seven years, I think we've come further in this conversation in the last seven than perhaps over the last, let's say, seven years. I think we've come further in this conversation|||你能分享的那一半信息？是的，不幸的是事实并非如此。公众绝不会对半路信息感到满意。我理解这一点。坦白说，我也会感到沮丧。但如果你看看这场对话在过去，比方说七年里是如何演变的，我认为我们在过去七年里在这场对话中取得的进展，可能比过去，比方说七年里还要多。我认为我们在过去七年里在这场对话中
in the last seven than perhaps over the last 70. And none of us had to violate our security oaths. More and more information's coming out every single day. More and more whistleblowers are ready to come out and testify in front of Congress and the American people to let them know what they know about legacy programs and the UAP topic. You asked me to define, by the way, what UAP is.
in the last seven than perhaps over the last 70. And none of us had to violate our security oaths. More and more information's coming out every single day. More and more whistleblowers are ready to come out and testify in front of Congress and the American people to let them know what they know about legacy programs and the UAP topic. You asked me to define, by the way, what UAP is.|||取得了比过去70年还要多的进展。而且我们谁也没有违反安全誓言。每天都有越来越多的信息被披露出来。越来越多的吹哨人准备站出来，在国会和美国人民面前作证，让他们了解自己所知道的关于遗留项目和UAP话题的信息。顺便说一句，你让我定义什么是UAP。
UAP is basically the new word for the old term UFO, or unidentified flying object. It was changed to UAP some time ago. One was because of the stigma, the taboo and stigma surrounding UFO. Look, anytime you say UFO, people think tinfoil hats and Elvis on the mothership. And that's what we're talking about.
UAP is basically the new word for the old term UFO, or unidentified flying object. It was changed to UAP some time ago. One was because of the stigma, the taboo and stigma surrounding UFO. Look, anytime you say UFO, people think tinfoil hats and Elvis on the mothership. And that's what we're talking about.|||UAP基本上就是旧词UFO（不明飞行物）的新称呼。不久前它被改成了UAP。原因之一是围绕UFO的污名、禁忌和污名化。听着，每当你提到UFO，人们就会想到锡纸帽和母舰上的猫王。而这正是我们所讨论的。
What we're talking about are things that are being intelligently controlled that can fly over controlled US airspace with complete anonymity and potentially over our sensitive military installations and have the ability to even interfere with our nuclear equities. So from a national security perspective,
What we're talking about are things that are being intelligently controlled that can fly over controlled US airspace with complete anonymity and potentially over our sensitive military installations and have the ability to even interfere with our nuclear equities. So from a national security perspective,|||我们讨论的是那些受到智能控制的东西，它们可以完全匿名地飞越受控的美国领空，甚至可能飞越我们敏感的军事设施，并且有能力干扰我们的核资产。因此，从国家安全的角度来看，
this is a very serious topic. It is a national security concern, but there's other aspects to this conversation that if you were to ask me, I would submit to you, the government has no business being involved in. So what do I mean? Make a long story short, if I was talking to a three-star or four-star general
this is a very serious topic. It is a national security concern, but there's other aspects to this conversation that if you were to ask me, I would submit to you, the government has no business being involved in. So what do I mean? Make a long story short, if I was talking to a three-star or four-star general|||这是一个非常严肃的话题。这是一个国家安全问题，但这场对话还有其他方面，如果你问我，我要向你指出，政府根本没有资格插手。所以我这话是什么意思？长话短说，如果我是在和一个三星或四星将军交谈，
about potentially our vulnerabilities regarding UAP and our nuclear equities, great conversation to have with a three-star general. But this is a conversation that affects everybody both equally and a little bit differently, meaning depending how you were raised and your cultural background, your religious background, this is a topic that affects us
about potentially our vulnerabilities regarding UAP and our nuclear equities, great conversation to have with a three-star general. But this is a conversation that affects everybody both equally and a little bit differently, meaning depending how you were raised and your cultural background, your religious background, this is a topic that affects us|||谈论我们关于UAP和核资产的潜在脆弱性，那和三星将军谈论是非常棒的。但这场对话对每个人的影响既是平等的又有点不同，这意味着根据你的成长经历、文化背景、宗教背景，这是一个会从以下方面影响我们的议题：
from a psychological perspective, a theological perspective, a sociological perspective, even a philosophical perspective. And in that instance, I'm not really comfortable with a three-star general necessarily dictating to me how I should feel about this topic. I was a product of the government, and there's a lot of things we do right,
from a psychological perspective, a theological perspective, a sociological perspective, even a philosophical perspective. And in that instance, I'm not really comfortable with a three-star general necessarily dictating to me how I should feel about this topic. I was a product of the government, and there's a lot of things we do right,|||心理学角度、神学角度、社会学角度，甚至是哲学角度。在这种情况下，我并不太乐意让一个三星将军来对我说我应该如何看待这个话题。我是政府的产物，我们有很多事情做得很对，
and then there's some things that we don't do very well. And is that because, well, a couple things. Is that because A, of their, where their interests lie and what their motives are and what they're looking to do differ from yours, there's our X, Y, and Z, and that might not align with you. Is that why? That may be some of it.
and then there's some things that we don't do very well. And is that because, well, a couple things. Is that because A, of their, where their interests lie and what their motives are and what they're looking to do differ from yours, there's our X, Y, and Z, and that might not align with you. Is that why? That may be some of it.|||但也有一些事情我们做得不是很好. 这是否是因为，好吧，有几件事。这是否是因为 A，他们的利益所在、他们的动机以及他们想做的事情与你的不同，这里有我们的 X、Y 和 Z，这可能与你的一致。是这样吗？这可能是其中的一部分。
I mean, let's face it, governments are designed to be solution oriented. What do I mean? We pay a lot of money with our tax dollars to make sure that our government has all the information it needs, all the intelligence it needs in order to make an informed decision to protect us. Now, when you have an issue like this, where you can see some of the capabilities, but you have no idea the intent behind these things,
I mean, let's face it, governments are designed to be solution oriented. What do I mean? We pay a lot of money with our tax dollars to make sure that our government has all the information it needs, all the intelligence it needs in order to make an informed decision to protect us. Now, when you have an issue like this, where you can see some of the capabilities, but you have no idea the intent behind these things,|||我是说，让我们面对现实吧，政府的设计本就是以解决问题为导向的。这是什么意思？我们用税款支付了巨额资金，以确保我们的政府拥有其所需的所有信息、所需的所有情报，从而做出明智的决定来保护我们。现在，当遇到这样一个问题时，你虽能看到其中的一些能力，却根本不知道这些事情背后的意图，
it leaves people scratching their head. And that's not a really convenient conversation to have with the American people, especially if you are part of the National Security Apparatus like the Department of Defense, like the CIA, right? I'll give you a case in point, back in the 1950s, when the CIA first commissioned the U-2 spy plane
it leaves people scratching their head. And that's not a really convenient conversation to have with the American people, especially if you are part of the National Security Apparatus like the Department of Defense, like the CIA, right? I'll give you a case in point, back in the 1950s, when the CIA first commissioned the U-2 spy plane|||这让人摸不着头脑。对于美国人民来说，这并不是一个很好启齿的对话，特别是如果你是国家安全机构的一部分，比如国防部，比如中央情报局，对吧？我给你举个例子，早在20世纪50年代，当中情局首次委托洛克希德臭鼬工厂研制U-2侦察机时，
with Lockheed Skunk Works, we wanted to build a plane that could fly higher and faster than anybody else in the world so we could fly manned reconnaissance missions over mainland Russia. By the way, in contravention to an existing treaty we had with Russia at the time. So the first few missions went off great.
with Lockheed Skunk Works, we wanted to build a plane that could fly higher and faster than anybody else in the world so we could fly manned reconnaissance missions over mainland Russia. By the way, in contravention to an existing treaty we had with Russia at the time. So the first few missions went off great.|||我们想要制造一架比世界上任何其他飞机飞得更高、更快的飞机，以便我们能够在俄罗斯本土上空执行载人侦察任务。顺便说一句，这违反了我们当时与俄罗斯现有的条约。所以前几次任务进行得非常顺利。
We flew the aircraft and you know what? The Russians didn't respond. And so we really thought our plane was invisible, it was flying faster and higher and we achieved mission success. It wasn't until the Russians developed the SA-2 surface to air missile and successfully shot one of our planes down
We flew the aircraft and you know what? The Russians didn't respond. And so we really thought our plane was invisible, it was flying faster and higher and we achieved mission success. It wasn't until the Russians developed the SA-2 surface to air missile and successfully shot one of our planes down|||我们驾驶着飞机，你知道吗？俄罗斯人没有做出反应。所以我们真的以为我们的飞机是隐形的，它飞得更快更高，我们取得了任务的成功。直到俄罗斯人开发了SA-2地对空导弹并成功击落了我们的一架飞机，
and paraded the Captain Powers and the wreckage of the aircraft in front of the world and the United Nations. Did they admit that they were tracking every single one of the flights from the beginning? They didn't even want to admit to their own people that we had a technology that they had no way of defending themselves against. It wasn't until they had a technology that they had no way of defending themselves against. It wasn't until they had a solution did they admit that they had a problem. And look, a lot of governments are that way, guys. It's not just the United States.
and paraded the Captain Powers and the wreckage of the aircraft in front of the world and the United Nations. Did they admit that they were tracking every single one of the flights from the beginning? They didn't even want to admit to their own people that we had a technology that they had no way of defending themselves against. It wasn't until they had a technology that they had no way of defending themselves against. It wasn't until they had a solution did they admit that they had a problem. And look, a lot of governments are that way, guys. It's not just the United States.|||并在全世界和联合国面前游行展示了鲍尔斯机长和飞机残骸。他们才承认从一开始就在追踪每一次飞行吗？他们甚至不想向自己的人民承认，我们拥有他们根本无法防御的技术。直到他们掌握了他们无法防御的技术。直到他们有了解决方案，他们才承认自己遇到了问题。听着，很多政府都是这样的，伙计们。不仅仅是美国。
It's not just Russia. It's not just China. Well, that's what I was going to ask. Don't you have like a cartoon sign right out on your toilet door that says Skunk Works? Don't you do that? Like a skunk is waving. So that's basically, that's the purpose of, I'm assuming your hearing a couple of weeks ago or any hearings like that lately,
It's not just Russia. It's not just China. Well, that's what I was going to ask. Don't you have like a cartoon sign right out on your toilet door that says Skunk Works? Don't you do that? Like a skunk is waving. So that's basically, that's the purpose of, I'm assuming your hearing a couple of weeks ago or any hearings like that lately,|||不仅仅是俄罗斯。不仅仅是中国。好吧，这正是我要问的。你的厕所门外面是不是挂着一个写着“臭鼬工厂”的卡通标志？你们不这样吗？就像一只臭鼬在挥手。所以这基本上就是，我假设你几周前的听证会或最近任何此类听证会的目的，
where the Congress has questions about what are these and what is the acronym, unidentified? Yeah, so now it's unidentified anomalous phenomenon. It used to be called unidentified aerial phenomenon. One of the issues we had actually with UFO, we talk about stigma and taboo, but the reality is it's not even accurate because a lot of times we're seeing these things
where the Congress has questions about what are these and what is the acronym, unidentified? Yeah, so now it's unidentified anomalous phenomenon. It used to be called unidentified aerial phenomenon. One of the issues we had actually with UFO, we talk about stigma and taboo, but the reality is it's not even accurate because a lot of times we're seeing these things|||国会会提出这样的问题：这些是什么？那个缩写词“unidentified”（不明）是什么意思？是的，所以现在它是不明异常现象。以前被称为不明空中现象。我们对UFO实际遇到的问题之一，我们谈论污名和禁忌，但现实是它甚至都不准确，因为很多时候我们看到这些东西
not necessarily even in our atmosphere, we're seeing them underwater, in low Earth orbit, where there isn't, yeah, so there's not, when we talk about it. Did you see the thing? Why don't we just say crazy shit? Like what are we doing? Why do we need to make it?
not necessarily even in our atmosphere, we're seeing them underwater, in low Earth orbit, where there isn't, yeah, so there's not, when we talk about it. Did you see the thing? Why don't we just say crazy shit? Like what are we doing? Why do we need to make it?|||甚至不一定在我们的大气层中，我们看到它们在水下、在近地轨道上，那里没有，是的，所以没有，当我们谈论它时。你看到那个东西了吗？我们为什么不说点疯狂的话呢？比如我们在干什么？我们为什么非要把它弄成……
Well, we do say that behind closed doors. Okay. Like we always need to address it, I don't know, underwater? Yeah, wait, didn't you see the thing? The thing that was released with the little, from the military or from the Navy, right? It was like, dude, we got it on the fucking camera.
Well, we do say that behind closed doors. Okay. Like we always need to address it, I don't know, underwater? Yeah, wait, didn't you see the thing? The thing that was released with the little, from the military or from the Navy, right? It was like, dude, we got it on the fucking camera.|||好吧，我们在闭门会议上确实会这么说。好吧。就像我们总是需要处理它一样，我不知道，在水下？对，等等，你没看到那个东西吗？那个由军队或海军发布的带有小……的那个东西，对吧？当时的感觉就像，老兄，我们特么用摄像机拍到了。
We got it on the, and it went under the water and it's on camera. I mean, it's. So we have a lot of that footage. And you know, when you talk about flying, there's really, when you understand what flying is, there's four fundamental forces. You have thrust, lift, drag, and weight.
We got it on the, and it went under the water and it's on camera. I mean, it's. So we have a lot of that footage. And you know, when you talk about flying, there's really, when you understand what flying is, there's four fundamental forces. You have thrust, lift, drag, and weight.|||我们把它拍了下来，然后它潜入水中，都被镜头记录下来了。我是说，它就是。所以我们有很多这样的录像。你知道，当谈到飞行时，实际上，当你了解什么是飞行时，有四个基本力。你有推力、升力、阻力和重量。
And when you understand that, you create wings and you create lift and you fly. These things don't have wings. They don't have any obvious signs of propulsion. They don't have rudders and elevators and ailerons. Anything that we would normally ascribe to, let's say, an airplane or some sort of aircraft or even missile, these things have none of that.
And when you understand that, you create wings and you create lift and you fly. These things don't have wings. They don't have any obvious signs of propulsion. They don't have rudders and elevators and ailerons. Anything that we would normally ascribe to, let's say, an airplane or some sort of aircraft or even missile, these things have none of that.|||当你理解了这一点，你就会制造出机翼，产生升力，然后你就能飞了。这些东西没有机翼。它们没有任何明显的推进迹象。它们没有方向舵、升降舵和副翼。任何我们通常归因于，比某种飞机或某种飞行器甚至导弹的东西，这些东西统统没有。
And yet somehow they are able to defy the natural effects of Earth's gravity. So to say that they're flying, that's not even really accurate. We don't know how they're able to. We know that they're moving, that's not even really accurate. We don't know how they're able to. We know that they're moving, but we don't know. Jay, you've seen, I mean, look, I have seen, I don't even pay attention to it as much as Sean has,
And yet somehow they are able to defy the natural effects of Earth's gravity. So to say that they're flying, that's not even really accurate. We don't know how they're able to. We know that they're moving, that's not even really accurate. We don't know how they're able to. We know that they're moving, but we don't know. Jay, you've seen, I mean, look, I have seen, I don't even pay attention to it as much as Sean has,|||然而它们不知怎么能够违背地球引力的自然效应。所以说它们在飞，甚至都不是真的很准确。我们不知道它们是怎么做到的。我们知道它们在移动，这甚至都不是真的很准确。我们不知道它们是怎么做到的。我们知道它们在移动，但我们不知道。杰，你见过，我是说，看吧，我见过，我甚至不像肖恩那样关注这方面，
but I have, we've all noticed in the last 10 years, I guess, how much more there seems to be footage of stuff. Now, I will say one thing. We had Neil deGrasse Tyson on four or five years, right near the start of doing this podcast, and he talked about the idea that, look, if there was really stuff, considering how many cameras there are in the world
but I have, we've all noticed in the last 10 years, I guess, how much more there seems to be footage of stuff. Now, I will say one thing. We had Neil deGrasse Tyson on four or five years, right near the start of doing this podcast, and he talked about the idea that, look, if there was really stuff, considering how many cameras there are in the world|||但我见过，我们大概都注意到在过去10年里，似乎有更多关于这方面的影像资料了。不过，我要说一件事。我们在做这个播客刚开始的时候，邀请过尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森（Neil deGrasse Tyson）做客四五年，他谈到了这样一个观点：看吧，如果真的有这种东西，考虑到世界上有多少摄像头，
now that everybody's got on their phone, we'd see much more definitive evidence. However, my counterpoint is we are seeing stuff because we're seeing video from airline pilots, military pilots, we're seeing stuff moving through the sky. I've seen a bunch of those. I saw the one recently that it looks like a big, it looked like a trash can almost.
now that everybody's got on their phone, we'd see much more definitive evidence. However, my counterpoint is we are seeing stuff because we're seeing video from airline pilots, military pilots, we're seeing stuff moving through the sky. I've seen a bunch of those. I saw the one recently that it looks like a big, it looked like a trash can almost.|||现在每个人手机上都有，我们本该看到更多明确的证据。然而，我的反驳观点是，我们确实看到了东西，因为我们看到了来自民航飞行员、军方飞行员的视频，我们看到有东西在空中移动。我见过好几个这样的。我最近看到一个，它看起来像个大……几乎就像个垃圾桶。
Do you know the one I'm talking about? That was a trash can. Was it a trash can? That was a trash can. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Let me ask you then, sir, without asking you to divulge something you might not be able to, can I just ask you generally,
Do you know the one I'm talking about? That was a trash can. Was it a trash can? That was a trash can. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Let me ask you then, sir, without asking you to divulge something you might not be able to, can I just ask you generally,|||你知道我在说哪一个吗？那是垃圾桶。那是垃圾桶吗？那是垃圾桶。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。那我想问您，先生，在不要求您透露您可能无法透露的信息的前提下，我可以大致问您一下，
are you aware of enough information that would make you think that there is some there there, that there is definitely unexplainable, legitimate stuff that you've seen repeatedly. 100%, and it's not just me. Look, you've already had, I don't know how close you've been tracking this topic, but we've already had a former director of national intelligence, a former director of CIA.
are you aware of enough information that would make you think that there is some there there, that there is definitely unexplainable, legitimate stuff that you've seen repeatedly. 100%, and it's not just me. Look, you've already had, I don't know how close you've been tracking this topic, but we've already had a former director of national intelligence, a former director of CIA.|||您掌握的信息是否足以让您认为其中确有猫腻，即确实存在您多次看到过的、无法解释的合法存在？百分之百，而且不只是我。听着，你们已经有了——我不知道你们追踪这个话题有多紧密——但我们已经有了前国家情报总监、前中央情报局局长。
We also had two former presidents of the United States all come out and say, yes, this is real. This is something to this. There are these objects that are able to, in fact, the director of, so when I left my program, ATIP, there were several iterations afterwards. The current iteration is called AERO, A-A-R-O, All Domain Anomaly Resolution Office,
We also had two former presidents of the United States all come out and say, yes, this is real. This is something to this. There are these objects that are able to, in fact, the director of, so when I left my program, ATIP, there were several iterations afterwards. The current iteration is called AERO, A-A-R-O, All Domain Anomaly Resolution Office,|||我们还有两位前美国总统都站出来说，是的，这是真的。这确有其事。有这些物体能够……事实上，主管……所以当我离开我的计划 ATIP 时，后来经历了多次迭代。当前的迭代称为 AERO，A-A-R-O，全域异常解决办公室，
and they are under the Department of Defense and the intelligence community. And they just said last week, they said, oh, Altamain Anomaly Resolution Office, and they are under the Department of Defense and the intelligence community. And they just said last week, they said, look, we are seeing things that defy our understanding of physics. It is a fact, we know they are there, we know it is real, whatever it is, and it's something that we need to figure out.
and they are under the Department of Defense and the intelligence community. And they just said last week, they said, oh, Altamain Anomaly Resolution Office, and they are under the Department of Defense and the intelligence community. And they just said last week, they said, look, we are seeing things that defy our understanding of physics. It is a fact, we know they are there, we know it is real, whatever it is, and it's something that we need to figure out.|||它们隶属于国防部和情报界。他们上周刚说过，他们说，哦，全域异常解决办公室，它们隶属于国防部和情报界。他们上周刚说过，他们说，看吧，我们正在看到违背我们对物理学理解的事实。这是一个事实，我们知道它们在那里，我们知道它是真实的，不管它是什么，这是我们需要弄清楚的事情。
And don't you think we live in a society now where people just don't care? Like, we could be visited by them and people are like, sure, whatever, I gotta go pick up my kids and get a run of the grocery store. And people are like, there's aliens? Okay, anyway, what's on TV tonight?
And don't you think we live in a society now where people just don't care? Like, we could be visited by them and people are like, sure, whatever, I gotta go pick up my kids and get a run of the grocery store. And people are like, there's aliens? Okay, anyway, what's on TV tonight?|||难道你不觉得我们现在生活在一个人们根本不在乎的社会里吗？比如，我们可能会被它们拜访，而人们的反应是：好吧，随便吧，我得去接孩子顺便去趟杂货店。然后人们会说：有外星人？好吧，不管怎样，今晚电视上有什么节目？
Like, it's just, people just aren't interested. Well, yeah, but that's a fun, well, we've created that. I know Scotty would probably take the day off from watching. This is true. We created that, we needed to dumb everybody down in order for a lot of different reasons and it just happens to work and it's become very handy for this.
Like, it's just, people just aren't interested. Well, yeah, but that's a fun, well, we've created that. I know Scotty would probably take the day off from watching. This is true. We created that, we needed to dumb everybody down in order for a lot of different reasons and it just happens to work and it's become very handy for this.|||总之就是，人们就是不感兴趣。好吧，是的，但这很有趣，好吧，这是我们创造出来的。我知道斯科蒂大概会请假不看。这倒真的。我们创造了这一点，出于许多不同的原因，我们需要把所有人都变得愚钝，而这刚好奏效了，并且对此变得非常顺手。
But I mean if you look at whether it's politics, whether it's whatever it is, if people were really aware of what is going on, and I am not a conspiracy theorist at all as you guys could probably attest to. But I do believe, I used to always joke, I'd say if we want to take over a country, one of these things, we don't need to drop,
But I mean if you look at whether it's politics, whether it's whatever it is, if people were really aware of what is going on, and I am not a conspiracy theorist at all as you guys could probably attest to. But I do believe, I used to always joke, I'd say if we want to take over a country, one of these things, we don't need to drop,|||但我的意思是，如果你看看无论是政治，还是无论是什么，如果人们真的意识到正在发生什么，正如你们可能能够证明的那样，我绝不是阴谋论者。但我确实相信，我过去常常开玩笑说，如果我们想接管一个国家，其中之一，我们不需要空投，
all we need to do are just drop DVDs of our stupid TV shows. And just do to them what we've already done to ourselves so that they become slobbering morons staring in front of their TV, like Sean and Scotty on it Wednesday night, and then you could do anything. You know what I mean?
all we need to do are just drop DVDs of our stupid TV shows. And just do to them what we've already done to ourselves so that they become slobbering morons staring in front of their TV, like Sean and Scotty on it Wednesday night, and then you could do anything. You know what I mean?|||我们唯一需要做的就是空投我们愚蠢的电视节目的DVD。然后对他们做我们对我们自己已经做过的事情，让他们变成流着口水、呆呆盯着电视机的白痴，就像周三晚上的肖恩和斯科蒂那样，然后你就可以为所欲为了。你知道我的意思吗？
You could walk into Sean and Scotty's house and you could take everything, and they wouldn't move, because they're like, look at this, they got housewives and they're bachelorettes. Ooh. Right, and then we just beat it. It's like a dial tone coming out of their mouths,
You could walk into Sean and Scotty's house and you could take everything, and they wouldn't move, because they're like, look at this, they got housewives and they're bachelorettes. Ooh. Right, and then we just beat it. It's like a dial tone coming out of their mouths,|||你可以走进肖恩和斯科蒂的房子，把所有的东西都拿走，而他们都不会动弹，因为他们会想：看这个，她们有《主妇》还有《黄金单身女郎》。哦。没错，然后我们直接撤。就像他们嘴里发出了电话忙音一样，
you know what I mean? Well, I'll tell you, that's an excellent point. I'll offer a counterpoint to that as well. When I was growing up, if I wanted to learn anything in school, I had to go to the library, take out an encyclopedia that's probably 10 years old by then, and thumb through it, maybe I'd find one or two paragraphs on something I was interested in.
you know what I mean? Well, I'll tell you, that's an excellent point. I'll offer a counterpoint to that as well. When I was growing up, if I wanted to learn anything in school, I had to go to the library, take out an encyclopedia that's probably 10 years old by then, and thumb through it, maybe I'd find one or two paragraphs on something I was interested in.|||你知道我的意思吗？嗯，我告诉你，这是一个绝佳的观点。我也会对此提出一个反驳观点。我小时候，如果我想在学校学点什么，我得去图书馆，借出一本当时可能已经有10年历史的百科全书，然后翻阅它，也许能在上面找到一两段关于我感兴趣的事情的描述。
Now, kids, the new generation, have in the palm of their hands, more technology, more capability, and the ability to access the globe virtually instantaneously. And I think they may, to some degree, even be more prepared. Look, when I was in the government,
Now, kids, the new generation, have in the palm of their hands, more technology, more capability, and the ability to access the globe virtually instantaneously. And I think they may, to some degree, even be more prepared. Look, when I was in the government,|||现在，孩子们，新一代人，他们的手掌心掌握着更多技术、更多功能，并且拥有几乎瞬间连接全球的能力。而且我认为他们在某种程度上甚至准备得更充分。听着，当我在政府任职时，
we knew about several studies that your taxpayer dollars paid for. And it was the conversation went something like this, are the American people ready to know the truth about UAP, about the reality of UFOs? And time and time again these studies came back and they said absolutely not. It'll cause some sort of social discord and it will create havoc and it'll be a destabilizing type conversation. Now, here we are seven years into the conversation, and last I checked, nobody's made a run on the banks, everybody's paying their mortgages,
we knew about several studies that your taxpayer dollars paid for. And it was the conversation went something like this, are the American people ready to know the truth about UAP, about the reality of UFOs? And time and time again these studies came back and they said absolutely not. It'll cause some sort of social discord and it will create havoc and it'll be a destabilizing type conversation. Now, here we are seven years into the conversation, and last I checked, nobody's made a run on the banks, everybody's paying their mortgages,|||我们知道几项由你们的纳税钱资助的研究。当时的对话大致是这样的：美国人民准备好了解有关UAP的真相、有关UFO的现实了吗？这些研究一次又一次地反馈说，绝对没有。这会引起某种社会不和谐，会造成混乱，这将是一场破坏稳定的对话。现在，我们讨论这个话题已经七年了，据我上次了解，没有人去银行挤兑，每个人都在按揭买房，
everybody's still going to PTA meetings. So I think this generation, actually the younger generation, may be better equipped to have this conversation to some degree because when we were growing up, we had a lot of Judeo-Christian influence and a lot of basically people saying, look, these are accepted norms, accepted conversations to have, and these are not,
everybody's still going to PTA meetings. So I think this generation, actually the younger generation, may be better equipped to have this conversation to some degree because when we were growing up, we had a lot of Judeo-Christian influence and a lot of basically people saying, look, these are accepted norms, accepted conversations to have, and these are not,|||每个人都还在参加家长会。所以我认为这一代人，实际上是年轻一代，在某种程度上可能更有能力进行这场对话，因为在我们成长的时候，我们受到了很多犹太-基督教文化的影响，基本上有很多人说，看吧，这些是被普遍接受的规范、可以进行的对话，而这些则不是，
keeping in mind that we, our government, placed about 70 years worth of artificial taboo and stigma on this topic. Most of the time, like I said, when you hear the word UFO, you hear about Elvis on the mothership and silly things like that. And that's not really what we're talking about.
keeping in mind that we, our government, placed about 70 years worth of artificial taboo and stigma on this topic. Most of the time, like I said, when you hear the word UFO, you hear about Elvis on the mothership and silly things like that. And that's not really what we're talking about.|||请记住，我们，我们的政府，在这个话题上施加了大约70年的人为禁忌和污名。大多数时候，就像我说的，当你听到UFO这个词时，你听到的是母舰上的猫王和诸如此类的愚蠢事情。而这并不是我们真正讨论的内容。
What we're talking about are things that have the capability to outperform anything we have in our inventory and have been able to do so for decades. Right, but the assumption along with that, or the implication is that these things have been sent from a place other than Earth. And so that comes with it, as to your earlier point,
What we're talking about are things that have the capability to outperform anything we have in our inventory and have been able to do so for decades. Right, but the assumption along with that, or the implication is that these things have been sent from a place other than Earth. And so that comes with it, as to your earlier point,|||我们讨论的是那些有能力超越我们库存中任何东西的事物，并且几十年来一直能够做到这一点。对，但随之而来的假设，或其暗示是这些东西是从地球以外的地方发送来的。因此，正如你刚才所说，随之而来的是，
issues of theology and scientific capability and on and on and on and on. Jason, can I offer something? Because you said something very, very interesting. When I was at ATIF. Fuck lives right in town, hang on. When I was a senior guy, When I was a senior guy, I was told a lot that people really
issues of theology and scientific capability and on and on and on and on. Jason, can I offer something? Because you said something very, very interesting. When I was at ATIF. Fuck lives right in town, hang on. When I was a senior guy, When I was a senior guy, I was told a lot that people really|||神学问题、科学能力等等等等。杰森，我能插句话吗？因为你刚才说了一件非常非常有趣的事。当我在 ATIF 的时候。真他妈就住在城里，等等。当我是一个高级人员时，当我是一个高级人员时，我经常被告知人们真的
can't handle the truth and whatnot. I think we can, I think we are in a situation now that is different than when I was growing up. I think, you mentioned about these things being from outer space, and when I'm asked are they from outer space, I say,'m asked are they from outer space, I say, well, they can be from outer space, inner space, or the space in between. So what do I mean by that?
can't handle the truth and whatnot. I think we can, I think we are in a situation now that is different than when I was growing up. I think, you mentioned about these things being from outer space, and when I'm asked are they from outer space, I say,'m asked are they from outer space, I say, well, they can be from outer space, inner space, or the space in between. So what do I mean by that?|||无法承受真相等等。我认为我们能，我认为我们现在的处境与我成长时不同。我想，你提到这些东西来自外太空，当被问及它们是否来自外太空时，我说，当被问及它们是否来自外太空时，我说，好吧，它们可以来自外太空、内太空或两者之间的空间。那我这话是什么意思呢？
I went to school, by the way, I'm not a conspiracy theorist either. I went to school to study medicine. So I graduated as a microbiologist and immunologist and studied parasitology. Not parapsychology, the study of parasites, microorganisms. And I was told it was, if you were to look at modern humans about the last two to 400,000 years, homo sapiens sapien,
I went to school, by the way, I'm not a conspiracy theorist either. I went to school to study medicine. So I graduated as a microbiologist and immunologist and studied parasitology. Not parapsychology, the study of parasites, microorganisms. And I was told it was, if you were to look at modern humans about the last two to 400,000 years, homo sapiens sapien,|||顺便说一句，我去上过学，我也不是阴谋论者。我去学校学的是医学。所以我毕业时是一名微生物学家和免疫学家，并研究了寄生虫学。不是超心理学，是对寄生虫、微生物的研究。我被告知，如果你看看过去大约20万到40万年的现代人类，智人，
we've been around what we think is a long time, but in reality, in the grand scheme of things, it's not really that long at all. So if you look at a 24-hour clock, and let's say the beginning of that being when we first became modern humans, it was only in about the last 15 minutes, the last 2000 years, that we realized
we've been around what we think is a long time, but in reality, in the grand scheme of things, it's not really that long at all. So if you look at a 24-hour clock, and let's say the beginning of that being when we first became modern humans, it was only in about the last 15 minutes, the last 2000 years, that we realized|||我们存在的时间在我们看来已经很久了，但实际上，在宏伟的大局中，这根本不算什么。因此，如果你看一个24小时的时钟，假设它的起点是我们首次成为现代人类的时候，那么直到大约过去的15分钟（也就是过去2000年），我们才意识到
the two primary forms of life on this planet. And it was the Greeks that suggested you're either a plant or you are an animal. And it wasn't until the last 10 seconds of our existence, right before it strikes midnight, the last hundred, sorry, the last 300 years ago, during the Renaissance or the days of enlightenment,
the two primary forms of life on this planet. And it was the Greeks that suggested you're either a plant or you are an animal. And it wasn't until the last 10 seconds of our existence, right before it strikes midnight, the last hundred, sorry, the last 300 years ago, during the Renaissance or the days of enlightenment,|||这个星球上的两种主要生命形式。是希腊人提出你要么是植物，要么是动物。直到我们存在倒计时最后10秒钟，也就是午夜敲响之前，最后一百，抱歉，最后300年前，在文艺复兴时期或启蒙时代，
that we discovered an entirely new form of life on this planet that is neither plant nor animal. And it was the world of fungus. And so we tap ourselves on the shoulder and say, clever little monkey. And it wasn't for the last five seconds of our existence, think about that, the last 120 years, that we actually discovered the true alpha
that we discovered an entirely new form of life on this planet that is neither plant nor animal. And it was the world of fungus. And so we tap ourselves on the shoulder and say, clever little monkey. And it wasn't for the last five seconds of our existence, think about that, the last 120 years, that we actually discovered the true alpha|||我们才在这个星球上发现了一种全新的生命形式，它既不是植物也不是动物。那就是真菌的世界。于是我们拍拍自己的肩膀说，聪明的机灵鬼。直到我们存在最后五秒钟的时候——想想看，也就是过去的120年里——我们才真正发现了真正的阿尔法
life form on this planet that's been here all along. In fact, if you take all the biomass of every plant, all the biomass of every animal, and all the biomass of every fungus and add it up together, it still does not add up to the biomass of this hidden life form that's been here all along. And it wasn't until we could curve glass and put in a little metal tube and famously shout the words, little beasties, little beasties, did we discover the world of microorganisms.
这个星球上的生命形式一直都在这里。事实上，如果你把所有植物的生物量、所有动物的生物量以及所有真菌的生物量加在一起，依然比不上这个一直存在于此的隐藏生命形式的生物量。直到我们能够把玻璃弯曲并装进一个小金属管里，并大喊出那句名言“小野兽们，小野兽们”，我们才发现了微生物的世界。
And so, is it possible that these things we're dealing with are just as natural to Earth as we are? Well, it's certainly a possibility. Could things be from underwater? Well, it's certainly a possibility. We know more about the surface of the moon than we do our own oceans. We have mapped less than 10% of the ocean floor.
那么，我们正在面对的这些东西，有没有可能和我们一样，对地球来说是完全自然的呢？嗯，这当然是一种可能。这些东西会不会来自水下？嗯，这当然是一种可能。我们对月球表面的了解甚至超过了我们自己的海洋。我们对海底的绘制比例还不到 10%。
Are the things, could they be from outer space? Sure, could they be interdimensional? And I don't mean interdimensional in kind of a woo-woo sort of way. I mean from a quantum physics sort of way, where a lot of our reality actually lies. So, it's a great question to suggest. Like traveling through black holes
这些东西，会不会来自外太空？当然会，它们会不会是跨维度的？我所说的跨维度并不是那种神神叨叨的方式。我指的是量子物理学的那种方式，我们现实的很大一部分实际上就 liegt 在那里。所以，这是一个很好的提问方向。比如通过黑洞旅行
that we might not even see yet. Absolutely, quite possible, right. We are learning more about space and time and the relationship that space and time is flexible. It's compressible, it's stretchable. And how likely is it that the UAP technology or these things that you're discovering or we're discovering is mistaken for technology
甚至是我们现在还看不见的黑洞。绝对的，完全有可能，对吧。我们对空间和时间以及时空具有柔韧性的关系有了更多的了解。它是可压缩的、可拉伸的。UAP 的技术或者你正在发现或我们正在发现的这些东西，被误认为是来自其他国家的技术的概率有多大？
from other countries? Is that a possibility as well? So it is, but here's the problem. Let's say this is a Russian, for example, Russian technology. That would mean that despite all the billions of dollars that we invest into our intelligence community, someone somewhere has developed this technology in secret,
这也是一种可能吗？是的，但问题来了。比方说，这是俄罗斯的技术，比如俄罗斯的技术。那就意味着，尽管我们在情报界投入了数百亿美元，但某人、某地还是秘密地开发了这种技术，
has been able to deploy it over our controlled US airspace, and there's not a darn thing we can do about it. So that would be equivalent to the greatest intelligence failure this country has ever endured, eclipsing that of even 9-11 by an order of magnitude. Let me just say this, let me just interject and say that I doubt it's Russia, this is
并能够在我们控制的美国领空上部署它，而我们却对此束手无策。所以，这将相当于这个国家经历过的最大情报失败，其严重程度甚至比 9-11 事件高出一个数量级。我只想说，我插话声明一下，我怀疑这不可能是俄罗斯，
the same country that's hiring mercenaries from Yemen to go and do some of their bidding in Ukraine, so I'm highly doubtful of it. Will, let's look at it temporally, right? So 1950s, we've been dealing, there's documentation right now that anybody can go out and look at from the US government from 1950s, early 50s that we've been dealing with this. Now, where were we? We had just entered the atomic age.
这是同一个国家，他们正从也门雇佣雇佣兵去乌克兰替他们卖命，所以我对此高度怀疑。威廉，让我们从时间维度来看看，对吧？所以从 20世纪50年代开始，我们就一直在处理这件事情，现在有任何人都可以去查阅的美国政府文件，从20世纪50年代、50年代初开始，我们就一直在处理这件事。当时我们在哪里？我们刚刚进入原子时代。
We had barely broken the sound barrier and we hadn't yet been into space. Where were the Chinese? Well, they're in the middle of a famine. And where was Russia? They were just developing the atomic bomb for themselves, still using, you know, proverbially horse drawn buggies to deliver it.
我们刚刚勉强突破音障，甚至还没进入太空。那中国在哪里呢？嗯，他们正处于大饥荒之中。俄罗斯在哪里呢？他们当时正在为自己研发原子弹，据俗话说，仍然在使用马车来运送它。
So that would be like walking into King Tut's tomb for the very first time in the 1920s and discovering a fully assembled 747 jet plane sitting inside the tomb. It doesn't make sense. All right, all right. Are you, are you, are you, what's your level of confidence that we're gonna learn something definitive
所以这就像在20世纪20年代第一次走进图坦卡蒙法老墓，却发现墓里停着一架完全组装好的747喷气式客机。这根本说不通。行，行。你，你，你，在你看来，在我们这些50岁的人死之前，
before us for what, 50 year olds die? Well, as part of, JB, as part of that, what is your level of confidence that you're gonna be able to divulge some of what you know and then also reveal more soon? Well, I think we are well down that path. I think we are having that conversation now within the legislative branch
我们弄懂一些确切事情的信心水平有多高？那么，作为其中的一部分，JB，作为这其中的一部分，你对于自己能够透露所知的一部分并很快揭晓更多的信心水平有多高？嗯，我认为我们已经在这条路上走了很远。我认为我们现在正在国会山
and the executive branch of our government. Politics aside, whether you're liberal or conservative, doesn't matter, this is truly a bipartisan issue. And I have seen both the Democrats and Republicans who would never, ever, ever even exchange glances with each other are literally sitting side by side having lunch talking about this topic.
以及我们政府的行政部门中进行这种对话。抛开政治不谈，无论你是自由派还是保守派，这都不重要，这确实是一个跨党派的议题。我见过那些平时绝对、绝对、绝对连眼神交流都不会有的民主党人和共和党人，如今却 literalmente 并肩坐在一起吃着午餐，讨论着这个话题。
That's right. Well, I'm bipartisan curious, by the way. It should be noted. Are you implying that there is something to know and the question only is when are we going to agree to let the public know it? Yeah, yeah, that's exactly what I'm saying. There is something to know that we're not being told.
没错。顺便说一句，我对跨党派也挺好奇的。应该指出的是。你是在暗示确实有些内情，而问题仅仅在于我们什么时候才同意让公众知道吗？对，对，我就是这个意思。确实有些我们不被告知的内幕。
Absolutely, oh, I testified before the American people and so did others. If I told you right now that we're not recorded and just between us and we're just gonna chill, we're all chill. We'll cut this out, we'll cut this out. How does that, I mean, you look at, I won't even say people's names,
绝对的，哦，我在美国人民面前作证过，其他人也是。如果我现在告诉你，我们没有被录音，这只是我们之间的小秘密，我们都很放松，大家都很放松。我们会把这段掐掉，我们会把这段掐掉。这感觉——我的意思是，你看——我甚至不说别人的名字，
but there are certainly people in the government or about to be in the government that would love to be the one that tells everybody finally this answer. Like, how has that not happened in a world of everyone sort of violating their NDAs and all that stuff? I can't believe somebody in the government with this clearance hasn't popped off
但政府中确实有些人，或者即将进入政府的人，会很乐意成为那个最终把这个答案告诉所有人的人。像这样，在每个人都在某种程度上违反保密协议等等的世界里，怎么会还没有发生过这种事呢？我简直不敢相信政府里拥有这种安全级别的人竟然没有爆料，
and written a book anonymously or something and said, here's all the goods. Well, people have, and unfortunately, there've been very serious repercussions for doing it. There have been attacks on the credibility, attacks on the reputation. Some of us have been physically threatened, unfortunately. There is a darkest. Really?
匿名写本书或者做点什么，然后说，所有的内幕都在这里。嗯，有人做过，但不幸的是，这样做会产生非常严重的后果。有人攻击他们的信誉，攻击他们的声誉。不幸的是，我们当中有些人甚至受到了人身威胁。这里有一个至暗的——真的吗？
Oh, absolutely. There is a definitely, one of my colleagues, Dave Grusch, who testified last year, was ripped to pieces, unfortunately. Some people in the CIA had leaked some dossier of his and they made it within 24 hours of him testifying. It was headline news that he sought some psychological counseling for PTSD.
哦，绝对的。绝对有，我的同事大卫·格鲁施（Dave Grusch），去年曾出庭作证，不幸的是，他被喷得体无完肤。中情局的一些人泄露了他的一份档案，并在他作证后24小时内就抛了出来。头条新闻赫然写着他曾因创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）寻求过心理咨询。
The attempt was trying to smear his credibility when in reality he was doing exactly what he was supposed to do as a combat veteran. But they tried to use it against him. Reprehensible, but. Well, it's unfortunate, because it seems like now more than ever, we could really use something like this
此举企图抹黑他的信誉，而事实上，他当时做的正是他作为一名战斗老兵应该做的事情。但他们却试图以此来对付他。这太卑鄙了，不过……嗯，这很不幸，因为似乎比以往任何时候都更能让我们真正需要这样的事情，
to really kind of shock everybody into this recognition of of unanimity and that that we're all humans on this one planet, even given all of our sort of micro differences, the macro similarity is that we're all human beings, regardless of party affiliation and all that stuff. And something like knowledge that stuff, and something like knowledge that aliens exist or something like this would might maybe just snap everybody into like, oh, we're all one.
来真正让所有人大吃一惊，从而认识到一致性，认识到尽管我们有各种微小的差异，但宏观上的共同点是，我们都是人类，抛开党派归属等等不谈。而诸如“外星人存在”之类的知识，或者类似的事情，也许能一下子让所有人猛然清醒过来，哦，原来我们都是一体的。
Well, then some other, whether it's aliens or that there's something else that exists that is beyond our, because it's not even a thing or a spacecraft or a ship or whatever, but just something that we can't even conceive of. That idea, the thing that the human brain can't even, that we can't imagine. It would right size our differences.
好吧，那么还有其他什么，不管是外星人还是存在着其他超越我们理解的事物，因为这甚至不是一个实体、一艘飞船或任何船只，而仅仅是我们甚至无法构想的东西。那个想法，人类大脑甚至无法企及、我们根本无法想象的东西。它会让我们正确看待彼此的差异。
Yeah, it's beyond our minds to create, you know, that idea. Well, I am, you know, cautiously optimistic. You could do that for America right now. I think there's a lot of, you know, the truth shall set you free is an old slogan from one of the agencies I used to work with. And, you know, I believe that truth is, and transparency is the best, you know,
对，这超出了我们大脑所能创造的范畴，你知道，那种想法。嗯，你知道，我是谨慎乐观的。你现在就可以为美国做到这一点。我认为有很多，你知道的，“真相将使你自由”曾是我以前工作过的一个机构的老标语。而且，你知道，我相信真相和透明度是最好的，你知道，
sunlight, right, is the best disinfectant. I think America can handle the truth on this topic, but I will tell you, there is some parts of this conversation that are very uncomfortable for some people because it may challenge some people's preconceived notions of, for example, their religion or the notion of certain government's preeminence, right?
阳光，对吧，阳光是最好的消毒剂。我认为美国能够承受这个话题的真相，但我必须告诉你，这场对话的某些部分对某些人来说非常不舒服，因为它可能会挑战某些人先入为主的观念，例如他们的宗教信仰，或者对某些政府至高无上的观念，对吧？
When people realize that maybe we're not the alpha life form necessarily, that could create a lot of anxiety for some people. God forbid. Right, so now they have to reconcile, well, maybe we aren't the top of the food chain per se. Civil unrest. What does that mean for us?
当人们意识到也许我们不一定是最高阶生命形式时，这可能会给某些人带来极大的焦虑。上帝保佑。对，所以现在他们必须去调和：好吧，也许我们本身并不是食物链的顶端。社会动荡。这对我们意味着什么？
Well, think about it, think about it this, I was just watching, I was just reading a thing, another thing, Jonathan Haidt, the guy who's been doing all this stuff, crusading against phone usage with our kids, etc., he wrote that, anxious generation. Amazing, but one of the things he was talking about was this idea that we're so nervous
嗯，仔细想想，仔细想想这个，我刚才正在看，我刚在读一篇文章，另一篇文章，乔纳森·海特（Jonathan Haidt），那个一直在做这方面工作的人，他一直在带头反对我们的孩子使用手机等等，他写了那本《焦虑的一代》。太棒了，但他谈到的其中一件事就是这种想法：我们对让孩子玩耍感到如此紧张，
about letting our kids play, and now they've increased the age parents have that they're comfortable letting their kids play outside to like, on their own, to like 12 years old or whatever, because they're so nervous about it. And I think about that, and we've gotten increasingly nervous about allowing ourselves, and I think about that and we've gotten increasingly nervous about allowing ourselves and I think about that idea. So imagine people are afraid to let their kids play outside until they're now 12 years old or whatever.
以至于现在父母愿意让孩子独自在外面玩耍的年龄已经提高到了比如12岁左右，因为他们对此感到太焦虑了。我想到这一点，我们对允许自己做某些事情变得越来越焦虑，我想到这一点，我们对允许自己做某些事情变得越来越焦虑，我一直在思考这个想法。所以想象一下，人们害怕让孩子在外面玩，直到他们现在12岁左右或更大。
Imagine the idea of turning upside down everything, not just about your religion, everything that you think this will affect the way you look at interpersonal relationships. This is an existential question, right? It'll look forever, people through art, through music, whatever people are always talking about looking for. Why? Why am I here? The great Greek philosophers, what is it all about?
想象一下，把一切都颠倒过来的想法，不仅关乎你的宗教，还关乎你认为这一切会影响你看待人际关系的方式。这是一个存在主义的问题，对吧？它将永远改变人们通过艺术、音乐等形式所追求的东西。为什么？我为什么在这里？伟大的希腊哲学家，这一切到底是为了什么？
Blah, blah, blah. Guess what? You're about to find out. Here's what it's all about. And it's going to fucking blow people's minds. Right? Throw out your drugs, you don't need them anymore. You know?
叭啦叭啦叭啦。你猜怎么着？你马上就要找到了。这就是这一切的意义所在。这他妈会震撼所有人的心灵。对吧？扔掉你的毒品，你再也不需要它们了。你知道吗？
You know, from a national security perspective, I had, this is a, let me see if I can give you an example of some of the conversations I had with some of the generals in the Pentagon about this topic. Because the first thing to ask me is, Lou, is it a threat? Yeah, I was just gonna say, like, what is the national threat, yeah? Yeah, to ask me is, Lou, is it a threat? Yeah, I was just going to say, like, what is the national threat? Yeah, so my response is, we don't know.
你知道，从国家安全的角度来看，我曾经——这是一个，让我看看能不能给你举个例子，谈谈我与五角大楼的一些将军们关于这个话题的某些对话。因为他们问我的第一件事就是：“卢，这是一个威胁吗？”对，我正要说，国家威胁到底是什么，对吧？对，问我的是：“卢，这是一个威胁吗？”对，我正要说，国家威胁到底是什么，对吧？所以我的回答是：我们不知道。
But here's the bottom line. In order to determine if something is a threat, it's a very simple calculus from a national security perspective. It's capabilities versus intent. Now, we've seen some of the capabilities. We have no idea the intent. So let me give you a little analogy here,
但最关键的是。为了确定某事是否是威胁，从国家安全角度来看，这是一个非常简单的计算公式。这就是能力与意图的较量。现在，我们已经看到了一些能力。但对于意图，我们一无所知。所以让我在这里给你举个小类比，
and I'll just start with you, Will. Let me ask you a quick question. I'm sure you live in a beautiful neighborhood, wonderful house, Taurus, right? Do you lock your front door at night before you go to bed? I do. Oh yeah. I do too.
我就从你开始吧，威廉。我问你一个简单的问题。我确信你住在一个美丽的街区，有着很棒的房子，还有金牛座汽车，对吧？你晚上睡觉前会锁上大门吗？我会的。哦，对。我也会。
And you know what? I would submit to you that probably most people do, even though you don't expect anything bad to happen. Let's say one night you go ahead and you lock your front door and you even take the extra step to make sure your windows are locked and you punch in the code, security code to your keypad for your alarm system
你知道吗？我要说的是，可能大多数人都会这样做，尽管你并没有指望会发生什么坏事。假设有一天晚上，你锁好了前门，甚至还采取了额外措施，确保窗户也锁好了，并在你的警报系统键盘上输入了密码、
and you go to bed. And now you wake up one Sunday morning, come downstairs, I have a nice hot cup of coffee or tea, and as you walk downstairs you notice size 11 muddy boot prints in your living room carpet that were not there the night before. Now, right, so no one's been hurt, nothing's been taken, but despite you locking the doors and the windows
安全密码，然后你上床睡觉了。现在你醒来在一个星期天的早晨，下楼来，喝上一杯热气腾腾的咖啡或茶，当你走下楼时，你注意到客厅地毯上有 11 号码带有泥土的靴印，而昨晚并没有这些脚印。现在，对吧，没有人受伤，什么东西也没拿，但尽管你锁好了门窗
and turning on the alarm, there are now muddy boot prints in your living room that were not there the night before. So my question to you is, is that a threat? So my response is, it could be if it wanted to be, so we better figure out how it's getting into the house. This is the same rationale from a national security perspective. We see these things coming into our airspace.
并打开了警报器，你的客厅里现在却出现了昨晚没有的泥泞靴印。所以我的问题是，这是一个威胁吗？所以我的回答是：如果它想成为威胁，那它就是威胁，所以我们最好弄清楚它是怎么进到屋里的。从国家安全的角度来看，这也是同样的逻辑。我们看到这些东西进入我们的领空，
There's not a darn thing we can do about it. They seem to be able to interfere with our nuclear equities, and they are very interested in our military capabilities. Is that a threat? Well, it could be if it wanted to be, so we gotta figure it out. Right, we don't know until, yeah.
而我们却对此束手无策。它们似乎能够干扰我们的核资产，并且它们对我们的军事能力表现出极大的兴趣。这是一个威胁吗？嗯，如果它想成为威胁，那它就是威胁，所以我们得把它搞清楚。对，在我们弄清楚之前我们都不知道，对吧。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's interesting. It's more, it could be if it wanted to be, so we gotta figure it out. Right, we don't know until, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's interesting. It's more, it's almost like, the equivalent is almost like in The Godfather with the horse head in the bed, it's like, you know, we could do this, we could do whatever we want, we're just letting you know we're here,
对，对，对，对。这很有趣。这更……如果它想成为威胁，那它就是威胁，所以我们得把它搞清楚。对，在我们弄清楚之前我们都不知道，对吧。对，对，对，对。这很有趣。这更……这几乎就像，等同于《教父》里把马头放在床上的那一幕，就像是，你知道的，我们可以做到这一点，我们可以为所欲为，我们只是让你知道我们在这里，
we're rattling your cage, now look, they might not, we might turn out to be so primitive that they're like, these ding-dongs think that we're threatening them, but we don't need to threaten them. We're just looking around. We're just like these little peons who are reacting.
我们在敲打你的铁笼，现在看，它们可能不会——我们到头来可能如此原始，以至于它们会觉得：“这些笨蛋居然以为我们在威胁他们，但我们根本不需要威胁他们。我们只是在四处看看。”我们只是像那些作出反应的小喽啰。
Are there protocols or safety measures in place for dealing with a possible whatever? Muddy boots? Muddy boots. There are, you know, we do a lot of war planning in the Pentagon for contingency planning. So, Mocs are ready. But it's, look, let me give you another example,
对于应对可能出现的各种情况，是否有相应的规程或安全措施？泥靴？泥靴。有的，你知道的，我们在五角大楼做了大量的战争规划来进行应急计划。所以，模组（Mods）已经准备好了。但你看，让我再给你举个例子，
Will, you just said, it could be just like us flying in a helicopter over the Serengeti looking at the wildebebeast, right? And let's say we go a step further and we dart, we decide to dart one and we tranquilize it and we land the helicopter, we pull blood from it and we're looking at its migratory patterns and its health and whatnot.
威廉，你刚才说了，这可能就像我们乘直升机飞越塞伦盖蒂平原观察角马一样，对吧？比方说，我们再进一步，我们射出一支飞镖，决定对其中一只进行麻醉，然后直升机降落，抽取它的血液，观察它的迁徙路线和健康状况等等。
Can you imagine for the perspective of that wilderbeast, now all of a sudden it wakes up, it kind of waddles over to the watering hole and it's like, Bill, you're not going to believe this man. But I was just sitting there by myself, all of a sudden something came down from the sky. All of a sudden people were touching me and things were happening to me and now my butt hurts.
你能想象从那只角马的角度来看吗？现在它突然醒了，它摇摇晃晃地走到水坑边，心想：“比尔，你绝对不会相信这事，伙计。我刚才独自呆在那儿，突然有什么东西从天而降。突然有人在摸我，有些事情发生在我身上，现在我的屁股好痛。”
Right? So. I had a similar experience, by the way, I'm not joking. The other night I was driving and I saw a coyote, or a coyote as some people say, erroneously. And I was driving right the other night I was driving and I saw a coyote, or a coyote as some people say, erroneously, and I was driving right here near my house and I saw this coyote and he was whipping along the street because I was driving my car, but he was freaking out
对吧？所以。顺便说一句，我有过类似的经历，我不是在开玩笑。前几天我开车时看到了一只郊狼（coyote），有些人错误地把它读成（coyote）。我当时正在开车——前几天我开车时看到了一只郊狼，有些人错误地把它读成（coyote），我当时正开着车经过我家附近，我看到了这只郊狼，它在街上飞奔，因为我开着车，但它被吓坏了，
and then he kind of got out of my way and then I was past him, I kind of slowed down and he went behind me, and I was thinking at that time, I was like, oh silly little coyote, I'm not going to hurt you. And I thought like from his perspective, he's like, oh my God, blah, and I was thinking at that time, I was like, oh, silly little coyote, I'm not gonna hurt you. Yeah. And I thought, like, from his perspective, he's like, oh my God, this huge machine with lights and blah, blah, blah, blah.
然后它避开了我，我从它身边过去后，稍微减速了一下，它走到我身后，我当时在想，哦，傻乎乎的小郊狼，我不会伤害你的。我想，从它的角度来看，它会觉得：哦，天哪，叭啦……我当时在想，哦，傻乎乎的小郊狼，我不会伤害你的。对。我想，从它的角度来看，它会觉得：哦，天哪，这个带着灯光和叭啦叭啦叭啦的庞然大物。
Yeah, for sure. And there I am, and I don't realize that I'm the coyote and I'm probably more scared and dumber than that coyote in the grand scheme of things, or we are. Right. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Luis, talk to Will and Jason about the animal mutations.
对，绝对是的。而我呢，却没有意识到我其实就是那只郊狼，在大局观中，我可能比那只郊狼更害怕、更愚蠢，或者我们都是如此。对。我们马上回来。现在，欢迎回到节目中。路易斯，跟威廉和杰森谈谈动物残缺的现象。
Yeah. Because that's crazy. Yeah, so I actually had the privilege of speaking to an individual in Montana. He works for the US Department of Agriculture and is one of the senior bovine veterinarians in Montana. And he is particularly concerned of what you refer to as cattle mutilations.
好的。因为那太疯狂了。对，其实我有幸跟蒙大拿州的一个人进行了交谈。他为美国农业部工作，是蒙大拿州的高级牛类兽医之一。他对你们所说的“牛只残缺”现象特别关注。
It's been going on for decades where farmers here in the United States and around the world have been having some of their livestock completely and totally gutted and disemboweled without any blood loss. In some cases, it looks like the wounds have been cauterized instantly by some sort of laser, no blood loss.
这种现象已经持续了几十年，美国的农民以及世界各地的农民发现，他们的一些牲畜被完全、彻底地掏空了内脏，却没有流血。在某些情况下，伤口看起来像是被某种激光瞬间烧灼过的，没有流血。
In other cases, very perplexing. One in particular I heard about up in Montana, where the only thing that was missing from the animal was a tiniest little bone from inside the ear. So when you look at natural predation in nature, you can expect, you just talked about a coyote, for example, you can see puncture wounds in animal flesh, you can see how the canines and the incisors
在另一些情况下，这非常令人困惑。我听说蒙大拿州发生过这样一件事，动物身上唯一缺失的是耳朵里面那块极小的骨头。所以，当你观察自然界中的自然捕食时，你会预料到——你刚才提到了郊狼，例如，你可以在动物的肉上看到穿刺伤，你可以看到犬齿和门齿是如何
will tear away flesh. That's not the case here. These animals, in some cases with surgical precision and a knowledge of anatomy, their sexual organs have been removed, in some cases their brains have been removed. Again, no sign of predation, no blood loss. It's as if someone came in with a laser scalpel
撕裂肌肉的。但这里的情况并非如此。这些动物在某些情况下带有外科手术般的精准度和解剖学知识，它们的生殖器官被切除了，在某些情况下，它们的大脑被取走了。同样，没有捕食的迹象，也没有失血。就好像有人拿着激光手术刀走进来，
and just decided to remove certain portions of the animal while leaving the rest behind. Okay, okay, okay. This is, I mean, first of all, who knows everything? Who's the one person, other than Sean, who's guessing everything? Who knows?
决定切除动物的某些部位，而把其余部分留在了原地。好吧，好吧，好吧。我的意思是，首先，谁知道所有事情？除了肖恩，谁是那个能猜到所有事情的人？谁知道？
Is there one, or is there a body of people who are sitting there going, A, laughing at us for worrying about elections and all that stuff, just saying, guys, you are wasting your goddamn time on the wrong thing. And who are those people? Yeah, is there a department that knows everything that there is to know?
有没有这样一个人，或者有一群人坐在那里，A，嘲笑我们担心选举和那些乱七八糟的事，只是说：“伙计们，你们在错误的事情上浪费该死的时间。”那些人是谁？对，有没有一个部门知道所有能知道的事情？
So historically, the CIA and the Air Force had managed this effort for the US government. And then you had some special operations units like Joint Special Operations Command, JSOC, who also appeared to have had a piece of it in the Department of Energy. To say that there was one particular group that had all knowing or all encompassing insights into this,
从历史上看，中央情报局和空军曾为美国政府管理这项工作。然后你还有一些特种作战部队，比如联合特种作战司令部（JSOC），他们似乎也在能源部参与其中。要说有一个特定的群组拥有对这件事的无所不知或包罗万象的见解，
I don't think so. I know that there were, when I had our program, ATIP, there was discussions in the hallways of a much older program, a legacy program that was involved for many, many years in this topic and really was involved in what we call now crash retrievals and trying to exploit that technology. But again, we get back to intent, don't we, right?
我觉得没有。我知道，当我掌管我们的项目（ATIP）时，走廊里流传着关于一个历史更悠久项目的讨论，这是一个遗产项目，多年来一直参与这个话题，并且真正参与了我们现在所说的“坠毁回收”以及试图利用该技术的行动。但话说回来，我们又回到了意图的问题上，不是吗，对吧？
We can look at something all day long from a nuts and bolts perspective and still not have any idea it's intent. You know, one way to look at this too, people say, well, is it possible there is no intent? Like artificial intelligence, it's just binary, it's just doing what it does. Yeah, that's absolutely a possibility as well.
我们可以整天从螺母和螺栓的角度来研究某样东西，却依然对它的意图一无所知。你知道，看待这件事的另一种方式是，人们会说：“嗯，有没有可能根本没有意图？就像人工智能一样，它只是二进制的，只是在做它该做的事。”是的，这也完全有可能。
You know, intent seems to be a very human thing. And when I say intent, I don't mean motivation. You know, when a shark bites a surfer, its intent isn't to hurt the surfer. The motivation is that it's hungry and it wants to eat. Humans are really, and some advanced primates are really the only animals on this planet that have true intent, where we can manipulate things
你知道，意图似乎是一件非常人类的事情。当我说意图时，我指的不是动机。你知道，当鲨鱼咬冲浪者时，它的意图并不是伤害冲浪者。它的动机是它饿了，想吃东西。人类，还有一些高等灵长类动物，确实是这个星球上仅有的具有真正意图的动物，我们可以为了实现我们的意图
in order to achieve whatever our intention is. Are we dealing with something that is not only very, very smart, very intelligent, but also has intent? Or is that more of a uniquely human thing, right? So these are all questions that are being asked philosophically from some of the scientists that are still part of this effort. By the way, we had some of the best theoretical physicists
而去操纵事物。我们面对的是一个不仅非常非常聪明、极具智慧，而且还拥有意图的东西吗？还是说这更像是一个人类特有的属性，对吧？所以这些都是一些科学家在哲学层面上提出的问题，他们仍然是这项工作的一部分。顺便说一句，我们项目中拥有一些最顶尖的理论物理学家、
and astrophysicists and mathematicians and scientists in our program. Based on, and I think I asked this before and I apologize if you gave me an answer, or I probably just didn't understand it, but based on your knowledge of the current pitch of understanding, do you anticipate having some answers
天体物理学家、数学家和科学家。基于——我想我之前问过这个问题，如果你给过答案的话我向你道歉，或者可能我只是没听懂——但根据你目前对理解程度的把握，你预计在我们死之前能得到一些答案吗？
before we die? Absolutely, no, I think within the next three to five years, you're gonna have a heck of a lot more clarity on this. That's what all the pharmaceutical companies say too. We'll have a cure in three to five years. All right, yeah, yeah. Well, do you think AI will help with some of this intelligence gathering?
绝对会，不，我认为在未来三到五年内，你对这件事情会有极其多的清晰认识。所有制药公司也都是这么说的。我们将在三到五年内找到治愈方法。好吧，对，对。好吧，你认为人工智能会帮助收集这些情报吗？
It is already. Yeah, gathering? It is already. Yeah, okay. It is already. We're using it to actually look at deep fake videos to determine if a UFO video is real or faked. And that's important when you're briefing members of Congress, right? You gotta be 100% accurate.
它已经在这样做了。对，收集？它已经在这样做了。对，好吧。它已经在这样做了。我们正在用它来分析深度伪造（deepfake）视频，以确定 UFO 视频是真的还是假的。当你向国会议员汇报时，这很重要，对吧？你必须做到 100% 准确。
And if not, it could blow up. Is AI gonna be able to ask tough questions that we can't or sort of sift through, not just images, but information? We don't even need to know to ask. Yeah, so artificial intelligence, unfortunately, its limitations are it's only as good as its teacher, right? And its teacher tends to be humans. What you prompt it.
如果不是这样，事情可能会炸锅。人工智能能提出我们无法提出的尖锐问题，或者不仅能筛选图像，还能筛选我们甚至不知道该去问的信息吗？是的，所以人工智能，不幸的是，它的局限性在于它取决于它的老师有多好，对吧？而它的老师往往是人类。你给它的提示。
So, yeah. Right, so. Well, Sean used to think that artificial intelligence was when he drank smart water and he thought like, he's like, if I just drink it, if I drink enough of it. Trying so hard. If I drink enough of it. You would think with our current level
所以，对。对，所以。嗯，肖恩以前以为人工智能就是他喝聪明水的时候，他心想：如果我只是喝它，如果我喝够了的话……非常努力地尝试。如果我喝够了的话……你可能会觉得以我们目前
of like global surveillance, that like every corner of this world has got a camera on it via satellite. So it would think that there wouldn't be any flying around this planet that goes undetected or unmonitored or stored or something. Is that a safe assumption? Unfortunately, no. With all due respect, when we actually started
的全球监控水平，这个世界的每一个角落都通过卫星装了摄像头。所以你会觉得，在这个星球上不会有任何飞行物能够逃过检测、监测、记录或其他什么的。这是一个安全的假设吗？不幸的是，并没有。恕我直言，当我们真正开始
calibrating our radar systems to look for UAP, something very interesting happened about a year and a half ago. We started tracking Chinese balloons that were wafting over the Northern Hemisphere and continental United States. If you remember the stories about these surveillance balloons. They've been there a long time.
校准雷达系统以寻找 UAP 时，在大约一年半前发生了一件非常有趣的事情。我们开始追踪飘浮在北半球和美国本土上空的中国气球。如果你还记得有关这些侦察气球的故事的话。它们在那里已经很久了。
The bottom line is we really don't have a very good handle on our, what we call, US aerodomain awareness. We're supposed to, but the sad truth is we don't. There's a lot of things in our skies that we do not have any visibility into. And that's part of the problem with UAP because potentially you could have a near air collision. And we've had this before with both private pilots
底线是，我们对所谓的“美国航空域态势感知”并没有很好的掌控。我们本该如此，但可悲的事实是，我们并没有。我们天空中的很多东西，我们完全没有可视能力。这也是 UAP 的问题所在，因为潜在地，你可能会发生近距离空中相撞。我们以前经历过这种情况，无论是私人飞行员
and also in some of our military pilots. Right, I read that too. Because these things are potentially made of material that we haven't programmed our detectors to detect? It's a little more complicated than that. Let me see if I can break this down for you, just from some of the performance parameters. There's five fundamental observables
还是我们的一些军事飞行员。对，我也读到过。因为这些东西可能由我们尚未将检测器编程以检测的材料制成？这比那要稍微复杂一点。让我看看能否为你剖析这一点，仅从一些性能参数来看。有五个基本的观测特征，
that we have noticed from an intelligence perspective that puts this technology leaps and bounds beyond anything we have. So the first observable is instantaneous acceleration. That's the ability to move from point A to point B very rapidly. Now, a human being like me, we can withstand about nine G-forces wearing a G-suit
这是我们从情报角度注意到的，这使得这项技术远远领先于我们拥有的任何东西。所以第一个观测特征是瞬时加速。这是指从 A 点极快移动到 B 点的能力。现在，像我这样的人类，穿着抗荷服可以承受大约 9 个 G 的重力加速度，
for a short period of time before you start suffering medical consequences like blackouts, redouts, and ultimately death. So if you compare that to, let's say, the General Dynamics F-16, right? The F-16 can pull about 16 to 17 Gs before you start having structural failure, meaning the airframe starts to disintegrate around you.
持续一小段时间，然后你就会开始遭受医疗后果，比如黑视、红视，最终导致死亡。所以如果你把这与——比方说——通用动力公司的 F-16 相比，对吧？F-16 在开始发生结构性故障之前，大约可以承受 16 到 17 个 G 的重力，这意味着机体开始在你周围解体。
What we are seeing are things that are doing 1,000, 2,000, 3,000 G forces, right? Well beyond anything that we have. And then you have the other observable, which is hypersonic velocity. That's five times the speed of sound, or roughly five times 763 miles an hour at sea level, roughly.
而我们所看到的是能承受 1,000、2,000、3,000 个 G 重力加速度的东西，对吧？这远远超出了我们所拥有的任何东西。然后你还有另一个观测特征，那就是高超音速。那是五倍音速，或者大致相当于海平面时速 763 英里的五倍左右。
So you're looking about 3,200 miles an hour. Now, do we have technology that can go that fast? Yes, we do. The Lockheed YF-12 SR71, the Blackbird for example, can do about 3200 miles an hour at the unclassified level. But when it wants to take a right hand turn, it takes roughly half the state of Ohio to do it. And yet what we are seeing are things
所以你看到的是大约每小时 3,200 英里。现在，我们有能开那么快的技术吗？是的，我们有。例如洛克希德 YF-12 SR71，“黑鸟”侦察机，在非保密级别下可以做到每小时约 3,200 英里。但当它想要向右转弯时，大约需要消耗半个俄亥俄州的面积才能完成。然而我们所看到的东西
that are not doing 3000 miles an hour, they're doing 10,000, 13,000 miles an hour, and they can execute immediate right angle turns in 180s. So these are some of the things that when you see them, you realize, okay, this is not our technology, this isn't Russia, this isn't Chinese, this is something completely different. What's the weirdest thing you've come across
不是每小时 3,000 英里，而是每小时 10,000、13,000 英里，并且它们可以立即执行直角转弯和 180 度大回转。所以这就是其中的一些东西，当你看到它们时，你会意识到，好吧，这不是我们的技术，这不是俄罗斯的，这不是中国的，这是完全不同的东西。你遇到过最奇怪的事情是什么，
that you still can't explain? How about that? You know, that what he just said. I know, of course, but I mean, like, if there's something specific. It's that? You know, that's what he just said. I know, of course, but I mean, like if there's something specific. It's so frustrating to not understand that technology because my God, we could, I bet you that could just solve
是你到现在都无法解释的？那个怎么样？你知道的，他刚刚说的那样。我知道，当然，但我的意思是，如果有什么具体的事情的话。就是那个？你知道的，那就是他刚才说的。我知道，当然，但我的意思是，如果有具体的事情的话。不理解那种技术真是太令人沮丧了，因为天哪，我敢打赌，只要拥有那样的技术和那样的工程师，就能为我们解决
so many things for us to just have technology like that and engineers like that. Here's what I suspect a little bit, and I think Sean, this is good news for you. Uh-oh. Oh God. I think that back in the day, back in the 70s, that some of these entities, these unknown entities,
如此多的问题。以下是我的一点猜测，我想肖恩，这对你来说是个好消息。噢不。哦天哪。我想在当年，在20世纪70年代，其中一些实体，这些未知的实体，
if you will, tried to soften the blow of blowing our minds by seeding, slow playing, and through stories, through storytelling. Battlestar Galactica, Flash Wars. They got into George Lucas' brain. And so my point is this, Sean, you might get to Tatooine. After all.
如果你愿意的话，试图通过埋下种子、缓慢推进以及通过故事、通过讲故事的方式，来减轻冲击，免得把我们的脑子震撼坏了。《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》、《星球大战》。他们钻进了乔治·卢卡斯的脑子里。所以我的观点是，肖恩，你可能会去到塔图因星。
After all this, you might get to fucking Tatooine. I'll go, I'll fucking go. But you think that we've got a shot, you think within the next three to five years maybe, get a significant breadcrumb here that can satisfy some of our curiosity and some explanation. What's the holy grail of that, of what Jay's saying?
毕竟。经历了这一切之后，你可能真的能去他妈的塔图因星。我会去的，我他妈一定会去。但你认为我们有机会吗，你认为在未来三到五年内，也许能在这里找到一条重要的线索，能够满足我们的一些好奇心并给出一些解释？这其中的终极目标是什么，也就是杰森所说的？
Like what's the holy grail piece of it? Well, you don't want to share technology and insight into breakaway technologies, knowing that there are rogue nations out there and non-state actors that would love to take that technology and do something bad with it, right? So that's terrifying. Imagine being able to fly over the White House
比如它的圣杯（核心价值）是什么？嗯，你不会想分享技术以及对突破性技术的洞察，因为你知道外面有流氓国家和非国家行为者，他们很乐意夺取这项技术并用它做坏事，对吧？所以这太可怕了。想象一下能够完全匿名且瞬间飞越白宫上空，
completely anonymously and instantly and do whatever you want and then leave. That's not exactly a good news situation for our national security. And so that's priority number one, right? How do you have this conversation while keeping it out of the hands of people who don't want to do good things with it?
随心所欲地做任何事然后离开。对我们的国家安全来说，这绝对不是一个好消息。所以这是第一优先事项，对吧？如何在将其排除在不想用它做好事的人手中的同时，进行这种对话？
Then you have other issues. How long have we known about this and how long have we kept it from the American people? There's liability there. There's a very significant problem. For example, look at this from a business perspective. You have company A, aerospace company A, and aerospace company B.
然后你还有其他问题。我们知道这件事多久了？我们对美国人民隐瞒了多久？这里面存在法律责任。这是一个非常重大问题。例如，从商业角度来看这一点。你有一家公司 A，航空航天公司 A，以及航空航天公司 B。
Someone in the government decides to take a very interesting piece of material that was found during a crash and gives it to company A. Meanwhile, 10 years later, company A becomes a multi-billion dollar aerospace corporation. Company B goes bankrupt and now 200 jobs are lost and people, investors now lose their money
政府中的某个人决定拿出一件在坠毁事件中发现的非常有趣的材料，并把它交给公司 A。与此同时，10 年后，公司 A 变成了一家价值数十亿美元的航空航天公司。公司 B 破产了，现在 200 个工作岗位没了，投资者们现在在股市上血本无归，
on the stock market because the company goes belly up. You know, there's like, there's security exchange committed SEC violations of doing that. You have to, in the government, you have to give everybody a fair chance to compete. And when you give an unfair advantage to company A over company B, there could be billions of dollars worth of liability in that alone, right?
因为这家公司倒闭了。你知道的，这就像，这触犯了证券交易委员会（SEC）的违规行为。你必须，在政府中，你必须给每个人公平竞争的机会。当你给公司 A 比公司 B 不公平的优势时，仅此一项就可能产生价值数十亿美元的法律责任，对吧？
And then you have the problem where people in government were telling people, members of Congress, nothing to see here, folks. Meanwhile, all along, there was a lot to see here. We were actually investigating this, and we learned a lot about it. What do you, do you, let me ask the same one phrase this do you have you been exposed to enough information in your life that that what you what you think
然后你还有另一个问题，即政府中的人曾告诉人们，国会议员们：“乡亲们，没什么可看的。”然而与此同时，一直以来都有很多值得一看的东西。我们实际上一直在调查此事，并且对它有了很多了解。你对——让我问同样的问题，换个说法——在你的一生中，你接触到的信息是否足够多，以至于你认为
you know or what you do know or what you've heard about or been exposed to that were the circumstances different that if we just knew that much that we'd all be blown away. Stuff that you're not willing to or can't talk about. Can you even say that? Yeah, yeah, sure. Absolutely there is, but let me just give this in a term that everybody will understand here.
你知道的、或者你确实知道的、或者你听说过或接触过的事情——如果情况有所不同，如果我们只知道那么多，我们都会被彻底震撼。那些你不愿意或不能谈论的事情。你甚至能说这个吗？对，对，当然。绝对有，但让我用一个大家都能理解的词来解释这一点。
We live in an incomprehensibly complex universe. And in fact, we judge our universe by the five fundamental senses which we have, which is if you can't touch it, taste it here, smell it, et cetera, we can't interact with it. And yet, if you had the ability to look at this world around you
我们生活在一个复杂得令人难以置信的宇宙中。事实上，我们是通过我们拥有的五种基本感官来判断我们的宇宙的，也就是说，如果你摸不到它、尝不到它、听不到它、闻不到它等等，我们就无法与它互动。然而，如果你有能力通过像手机视觉这样简单的事情
through something as simple as cell phone vision, and now you can see in 5G and in Wi-Fi and GPS, you would see an entirely different reality around you. For example, I live here in Wyoming. Beautiful, un-included night skies, but if you look at that same portion of the night sky through, let's say, infrared, you will see nebulae, you'll see a whole different reality in front of you
来观察你周围的这个世界，现在你可以看到 5G、Wi-Fi 和 GPS，你就会看到一个完全不同的现实世界围绕着你。例如，我住在怀俄明州。美丽、未受污染的夜空，但如果你通过比如红外线来观察同一片夜空，你会看到星云，你会看到你面前一个完全不同的现实，
that's just as real as the reality you live in now, in fact, maybe even more real. The problem is we can't interact with it. The way we look at the universe through vision alone is only 0.0035% of the entire electromagnetic spectrum, meaning most of the universe remains hidden because it lies within a frequency beyond what we can perceive.
它和你们现在生活的现实一样真实，事实上，可能甚至更真实。问题是我们无法与它互动。我们仅仅通过视觉来观察宇宙的方式，只占整个电磁波谱的 0.0035%，这意味着大部分宇宙仍然隐藏着，因为它位于我们感知能力之外的频率范围内。
And then you've got the other challenge of size. So as big as this universe is, most people don't really understand just how big. By the way, just to interrupt, Jason, still applies size, doesn't matter, you're good, it doesn't matter. Okay, okay, thank you. Okay, okay.
然后你还要面对大小的挑战。所以，尽管这个宇宙如此之大，大多数人其实并不真正理解它究竟有多大。顺便说一句，打断一下，杰森，这仍然适用，大小并不重要，你很好，这没关系。好的，好的，谢谢。好的，好的。
I won't comment on that. I just saw him get nervous because you've been told so many times, he's fine. I'm fine, right? Luis, tell me before I let you go, because by the way, this has been. It's mind blowing. Mind blowing.
我对这个不予置评。我刚才看到他变得紧张，因为你被告知了太多次，他很好。我很好，对吧？路易斯，在我放你走之前告诉我，因为顺便说一句，这真的是……这太震撼了。震撼心灵。
It's incredible. You have a book called Imminent, which I'm getting. It's Inside the Pentagon's Hunt for UFOs. It's called Imminent. And I haven't read it yet, but I can't wait to read it. And you wrote it. What was your wife's reaction? I think I wrote about it.
这太不可思议了。你有一本书叫《迫在眉睫》（Imminent），我打算买一本。讲的是五角大楼对 UFO 的搜寻。书名叫《迫在眉睫》。我还没读，但我等不及要读了。这是你写的。你妻子有什么反应？我想我写过这个。
Yeah, let's just say my involvement in the UFO program went over like a lead balloon. Mrs. Elizondo was not very happy about that. Just to go back to what you were talking about, and I don't mean to oversimplify it or make it too brief, but are you basically saying that, in answer to your question to oversimplify it or make it too brief, but are you basically saying that the answer to your question to Will, the stuff that you do know that you're not able to share
好吧，这么说吧，我参与 UFO 项目就像一块铅沉入水底一样不受欢迎。伊利桑多夫人对此并不是很高兴。回到你刚才谈到的，我并不是想把它过分简化或说得太简短，但你基本上是在说，为了回答你对威廉的提问，把它过分简化或说得太简短，但你基本上是在说，回答你对威廉的提问，那些你确实知道却无法分享的事情
with us that you are convinced would blow our minds, that the sort of the context of that, the root of that, lives in what you're talking about, which is the stuff that's amazing is kind of like all of this stuff we can't see, like cell towers or radio frequencies and television stuff that's going through the air that we can't see. It all kind of lives in there and then eventually
和我们交流时你确信会让我们大开眼界，而这一切的语境、根源，其实都包含在你刚才所谈论的内容中，那就是最神奇的事物其实就像我们看不见的各种东西，比如手机信号塔、无线电频率以及在空中传播我们却看不到的电视信号。它们都存在于那里，然后最终
we're gonna kind of learn about this stuff that, yeah, there's all this stuff around and we just have never seen it because you can't see it just like cell tower technology. The space in between. Yeah, in essence, look, today's technology was yesterday's magic. And that's just the fact, right?
我们会开始了解这些东西，是的，周围有这么多的东西，而我们却从未见过，因为你看不到它们，就像手机信号塔技术一样。两者之间的空间。是的，从本质上讲，你看，今天的科技就是昨天的魔法。这就是事实，对吧？
And what we consider paranormal, by the definition of science, everything in science is paranormal until it becomes normal. That's just the world we live in. And so we have to recalibrate a little bit how we think about things and how we look at ourselves and our place in the universe.
而我们认为的灵异现象，根据科学的定义，科学中的一切在变成正常之前都是灵异现象。这就是我们生活的世界。因此，我们需要稍微重新调整一下我们思考事物的方式，以及我们如何看待自己和我们在宇宙中的位置。
Like I said, imagine this universe being 100 billion light years across and we're this tiny little speck in the middle. And as big as that seems, if you look at one hydrogen molecule, Avogadro's number, one times six something times 10 to the negative 23rd, that's roughly the same order of scale, guys. Meaning, as small as we are to the universe,
就像我说的，想象这个宇宙有1000亿光年宽，而我们只是中间一个极小的微粒。尽管这听起来很大，但如果你看一个氢分子，阿伏伽德罗常数，1乘以6点几再乘以10的负23次方，这差不多是同一个数量级，伙计们。这意味着，相对于宇宙而言，我们是多么渺小，
if you compare an atom to our body, that's roughly the same order of magnitude. We, as a species, can only interact with one or two degrees order of a magnitude up or down. Otherwise, the universe is simply too big or too small and we'll never be able to interact with it. I love that, I think that's fascinating. Yeah, that's where most of reality lives.
如果你把一个原子和我们的身体相比，这大约是相同的数量级。我们作为一个物种，只能与向上或向下的一两个数量级进行交互。否则，宇宙实在太庞大或太微小，我们将永远无法与之交互。我喜欢这个，我觉得这太迷人了。是的，现实的大部分就存在于那里。
Yeah, now, final question, Luis. What's the story? Can you explain why Sean and Scotty won't go past five block radius from their house? Is this related to that? It's a microcosm. Yeah, we're the atom of our neighborhood. Final question, Luis, what's a talent or skill
好的，现在，最后一个问题，路易斯。到底是怎么回事？你能解释一下为什么肖恩和斯科蒂不愿离开他们家方圆五个街区的范围吗？这跟这个有关系吗？这是一个缩影。是的，我们就是我们社区的原子。最后一个问题，路易斯，有什么才华或技能
people would never expect you to have? Oh my God, you got any theater stories? Yeah, you got any theater stories? Ever forget your line on stage? Okay, so there's three things that, so despite looking like I'm from Iowa, I'm actually Cuban, so I speak Spanish, and I'm Hispanic, so we do three things
人们绝对想不到你会有？天哪，你有什么戏剧圈的故事吗？对，你有什么戏剧圈的故事吗？在舞台上忘过词吗？好吧，有三件事，所以尽管我看起来像来自爱荷华州，但我其实是个古巴人，所以我说西班牙语，我是个西班牙裔，所以我们生来就挺擅长做三件事的。
coming out of the womb quite well. One is we smoke cigars quite well. We kind of, it's genetic for us, I guess. Two, we can dance salsa and merengue pretty well. And the third thing I probably can't discuss over the airwaves is probably not appropriate. But those are kind of the three things that as Latinos, we do.
第一是雪茄抽得很好。我们某种程度上，我想这对我们来说是基因决定的。第二，我们能把萨尔萨舞和梅伦格舞跳得相当好。第三件事我可能不能在广播里讨论，可能不太合适。但这些大概就是我们作为拉丁裔擅长的三件事。
Nice, nice, very nice. Sure, that's great. Can you once and for all also say that definitively that, cause Sean said in the opening that. By the way, I was talking about drinking rum. If anybody has any questions. No, I know, I know, of course you were. Right, right, for sure, for sure.
不错，不错，非常好。当然，太棒了。你能一劳永逸地明确说一下吗，因为肖恩在开场时说过。顺便说一句，我说的是喝朗姆酒。如果任何人有什么问题的话。不，我知道，我知道，你当然是。对，对，肯定的，肯定的。
Good for you. Yeah, yeah, yeah, just wanna make sure I clarify that. But Sean went to say that whatever, Gwyneth Walston High School or whatever, Glen Ellyn Illyn is the best, but it's not, whatever, it's not the best, right? We have evidence to support this. It's kind of the best.
那就好。对，对，对，只是想确保我澄清这一点。但肖恩接着说，不管是格温妮丝·沃尔斯顿高中还是什么的，格伦埃尔林是最好的，但它不是，不管怎样，它不是最好的，对吧？我们有证据来支持这一点。这算得上是最好的。
Don't answer that, don't answer that. Luis, I plead the fifth. It's a pleasure having you on. What a pleasure, oh my God. I've watched you in documentaries, I've watched you in Congress. I just think what you're doing is incredible and thank you for.
别回答那个，别回答那个。路易斯，我拒绝回答。很高兴你能来。太荣幸了，天哪。我在纪录片里看过你，我在国会听证会上看过你。我只是觉得你所做的事不可思议，谢谢你。
Yeah, keep it going, please. And by the way, part, thank you for your service to the country as well. Gentlemen, it's always a team effort. Thank you very much. By the way, my two daughters, who also work for the government, are huge fans of you guys.
对，请继续保持。顺便说一句，还有，谢谢你为国家所做的贡献。先生们，这始终是一个团队合作。非常感谢。顺便说一句，我的两个女儿也在政府工作，她们是你们的超级粉丝。
Oh, tell them about it. When they found out I was, oh, I absolutely will. When I told them I was gonna do your show, I think both of them were about to jump out the window. They were so excited. That's very true. Can you also make us this,
哦，告诉他们这件事。当他们发现我是，哦，我绝对会的。当我告诉他们我要上你们的节目时，我想他们俩都快激动得跳窗户了。他们太兴奋了。千真万确。你能不能也让我们，
if you get the green light to kinda like divulge a bunch of stuff, will you just give us a heads up real quick? Yeah, yeah. We really wanna know. We're so curious, but we really wanna know. We love breaking news on this show. You have my word.
如果你拿到绿灯可以透露一堆事情的话，你会不会提前给我们透露一点风声？会，会的。我们真的很想知道。我们太好奇了，但我们真的想知道。我们喜欢在这个节目里爆料。我向你保证。
But we'll be sure to pick up your book. And thank you for spending some time with us. Thanks, Luis. Guys, I appreciate it. Look, I didn't come on here to plug a book. Just wanted to have a conversation with you guys. No, I didn't. Of course I love it.
不过我们一定会去买你的书。谢谢你抽时间陪我们。谢谢你，路易斯。伙计们，我很感激。听着，我来这里可不是为了宣传一本书。只是想和你们聊聊天。不，我不是。当然我很喜欢。
Appreciate it. Yeah. But if there's anything you guys, ever have any questions, let me know. Thank you, sir. Okay, thanks, buddy. We got a lot. We got a lot.
非常感谢。是的。但如果你们以后有什么问题，随时告诉我。谢谢你，先生。好的，谢谢，老兄。我们聊了很多。我们聊了很多。
Nice to meet you. Enjoy your day. Take care, Joe. Bye-bye. Wow, wow, wow. Isn't that guy great? Wow, wow, buddy. We got a lot. Nice to meet you. Enjoy your day. Take care, Joe. Bye-bye. Wow, wow, wow. Isn't that guy great? Wow, wow, wow. Hey, look, can we make a commitment that we're gonna have more non-actors on this show?
很高兴认识你。祝你有美好的一天。保重，乔。再见。哇，哇，哇。那家伙难道不是很棒吗？哇，哇，老兄。我们聊了很多。很高兴认识你。祝你有美好的一天。保重，乔。再见。哇，哇，哇。那家伙难道不是很棒吗？哇，哇，哇。嘿，听着，我们能不能作出一个承诺，以后在这个节目里邀请更多非演员来？
I said to Will last week, I was like, you're gonna fucking love this guy. I know, Sean, I was trying to think, you kept saying, you were trying to send me, you were like, you're gonna go crazy, you're gonna love, and you were so right. But you'd never seen Luis in- No!
我上周对威尔说，我当时就说，你他妈一定会爱死这家伙的。我知道，肖恩，我在想，你一直说，你一直在暗示我，你当时说，你会疯掉的，你会爱上的，你真的太对了。但你以前从来没见过路易斯——没有！
Like documentaries or anything? No. Yeah, and he's always in, I testify in Congress. I don't know what kind of time you think I have. Yeah, man, what, you think I'm just like going down wormholes on YouTube for congressional reports? Pfft!
比如看纪录片什么的？没有。对，他一直在，我在国会作证。你觉得我有什么时间？是啊，老兄，什么，你觉得我是在YouTube上为了国会报告而钻牛角尖吗？呸！
Ha ha ha ha! Hey, it was interesting in front of Congress this week. By the way, the other day I was reading in bed in the middle of the day, it was on a Saturday, so I was just enjoying myself. And Abel said, my fourth-generation was like, hey, Bubba, we're texting, he's in the house and he goes, where are you? And I go, I'm in my bed reading. He just writes nerd.
哈哈哈哈！嘿，这周在国会面前作证挺有意思的。顺便说一句，有一天我大白天在床上看书，那天是星期六，所以我只是在享受生活。阿贝尔说，我的第四代说，嘿，巴巴，我们在发短信，他在屋里，然后他说，你在哪？我说，我在床上看书。他直接回了个书呆子。
Nerd. Hey, that guy, I got to tell you, man, you know, as we start to get more and more of these bigger breadcrumbs about what is and what isn't, I think we're gonna find out a little bit more what is, and it is going to make us feel appropriately smaller and more naive and more humble, and I think I'm ready for that.
书呆子。嘿，那家伙，我得告诉你，老兄，你知道的，随着我们开始获得越来越多关于什么是真、什么不是真的蛛丝马迹，我想我们会更多地了解到真相是什么，这会让我们觉得自己确实更加渺小、更加天真、也更加谦卑，我想我已经准备好接受这一切了。
I bet you most of the world is ready for that and can bear a little bit of a- Sean, you're ready. I mean, you live in this world. You want to know, but are you worried? Are you worried that there might be information that will blow your mind too much? No, I don't think so.
我敢打赌世界上大多数人已经准备好面对这一切，并且能够承受一点——肖恩，你准备好了。我的意思是，你生活在这个世界里。你想知道，但你担心吗？你担心会有一些信息彻底颠覆你的三观吗？不，我不这么认为。
Well, I think, look, some people wanna know, I think that information like this, I think that it runs the risk of really bifurcating. Bifurcating everybody. There's too much of a sentence left afterwards. Yeah. Okay, sorry, don't accept it. Okay. You should have said the sentence and then said, now that would be very bifurcating. There's too much of a sentence left afterwards. Yeah. Okay, sorry. Don't accept it.
嗯，我觉得，你看，有些人想知道，我觉得这样的信息，我觉得它有真正造成严重分裂的风险。把每个人都分裂开。后面留下的句子太长了。对。好吧，抱歉，不接受。好吧。你本应该把话说完，然后说，现在那可真够分裂的。后面留下的句子太长了。对。好吧，抱歉。不接受。
Okay. You should have said the sentence and then said, now that would be very... Bye, Frickada. It might be, bye, Frickada. Bye, Frickada. Bye. Okay, bye. Smart.
好吧。你本应该把话说完，然后说，现在那可真会……拜，弗里卡达。可能会是，拜，弗里卡达。拜，弗里卡达。再见。好的，再见。聪明。
Loss. Smart. Loss. Smart. Loss. Smart. Loss. Smart.
迷失。聪明。迷失。聪明。迷失。聪明。迷失。聪明。
Loss. Smart. Loss. Smart. Loss. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
迷失。聪明。迷失。聪明。迷失。SmartLess由贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗伯·阿尔姆贾夫（Rob Armjarff）100%有机手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。